und wir geben an dieser Stelle ab in den
Deutschen Bundestag da hat die Sitzung
soeben begonnen meine Kollegin Jeanette
Clark wird das für sie kommentieren und
ihnen sagen worum es genau geht der
Bundestag hat über vielen Dank und
natürlich bleiben wir beim Thema das war
ja schon eine Vorlage der Bundestag der
wird heute erstmals über die geplante
Laufzeitverlängerung der verbliebenen
drei deutschen Atomkraftwerke
debattieren in einigen Minuten wird es
der Fall sein gerade hat die
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Bars die
Sitzung eröffnet und zu Beginn einer
Sitzung da gibt es immer noch einige
formaljahr die für diese Sitzungswoche
besprochen werden müssen und wir hören
mal kurz rein
Tagesordnungspunkt 12 soll mit einer
veränderten debattenzeit von nunmehr 39
Minuten aufgerufen werden weiter sollen
die Tagesordnungspunkte 13 und 26 mit
den ohne debattenpunkten aufgerufen
werden
die Tagesordnung der schon beim morgigen
Tag vielleicht für Sie verehrte
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer noch einen
Blick auf den heutigen Tag also wie
gesagt wir erwarten gleich die Debatte
erste Lesung ist es ja zum Gesetz zum
Änderungen des Atomgesetzes also das ist
überhaupt mögliche wird dass die drei
verbliebenen deutschen Atomkraftwerke
bis potenziell zum 15 April 2023 laufen
sollen allerdings ist das den Plänen
zufolge nicht ununterbrochen und auch
nicht mit voller Leistung der Fall also
da werden wir wahrscheinlich in der
Debatte auch noch einiges zu hören schon
am Freitag soll das ganze dann in
zweiter und dritter Lesung hier durch
den Bundestag und thematisch schließlich
dann heute noch an an diese Debatte zu
den Atomlaufzeiten die Befragung der
Bundesregierung und hier steht die ja
auch für nukleare Sicherheit zuständige
Bundesumweltministerin Steffi Lemke Rede
und Antwort also eine Stunde hier eine
gute Stunde die eben Abgeordneten und im
weiteren Verlaufe heute nachmittags
steht dann auch noch eine vereinbarte
Debatte über die Bekämpfung des
Antisemitismus auf der Tagesordnung
Anlass ist ja dieser historische dieses
historische Datum heute der 9 November
der jahrestag der
Reichspogromnacht 1938
ciales aufmerksam weitere Überweisungen
sind dem Anhang der zusatzpunkteliste zu
entnehmen sie sehen die Tagesordnung ist
sehr dynamisch in dieser Woche
gibt es weitere Vorschläge das sehe ich
nicht dann sind sie soweit mit den
Änderungen einverstanden ich höre kein
Widerspruch dann ist das so beschlossen
ich rufe nun auf den Tagesordnungspunkt
1 erste Beratung des von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurfs zur Erhöhung des
Wohngeldes eine Aussprache ist für heute
nicht vorgesehen interfraktionell wird
vorgeschlagen den Gesetzentwurf auf
Drucksache
4.230 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse zu überweisen ja
das sozusagen formal der erste
Tagesordnungspunkt aber ohne Aussprache
da geht es ja um die zweite große
Sozialreform neben dem Bürgergeld der
Ampelkoalition dem Wohngeld plus also
wegen der steigenden Energiepreise
sollen ja einkommensschwache Haushalte
bei den Wohnkosten unterstützt werden
das ganze geht aber erstmal in die
Ausschüsse und wird dann morgen hier im
Bundestag beraten so jetzt geht es aber
los mit der ersten Lesung
Veränderung des Atomgesetzes die
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel bas hat
jetzt diesen Tagesordnungspunkt
aufgerufen
und erste Rednerinnen die
bundesumweltministerinnen für nukleare
Sicherheit ist ihr auch zuständig Steffi
Lemke
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir beraten
heute die 19 Änderung des Atomgesetzes
und ich muss eingangs ganz klar sagen
mir wäre es lieber wenn diese Änderung
des Atomgesetzes nicht erforderlich wäre
Deutschland hat sich aus sehr guten
Gründen entschlossen aus der Atomkraft
auszusteigen und heute beraten wir
darüber dass wir den Atomausstieg
angesichts der sehr schwierigen Lage auf
dem Energiemarkt um dreieinhalb Monate
nach hinten verschieben wir sehen uns
dazu gezwungen weil Russland in seinem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine versucht mit seiner fossilen
Erpressung die Unterstützung des
demokratischen Europa für die
ukrainischen für den ukrainischen
Freiheitskampf zu schwächen und weil das
Abwürgen der Energiewende und der
verhängnisvolle Pakt mit dem billigen
Gas in 16 Jahren unionsgeführter
Bundesregierungen zu dieser fossilen
Erpressbarkeit geführt haben
ich sage dazu ganz klar wir lassen uns
nicht erpressen und Atomkraft kann jetzt
einen Beitrag dazu liefern besser über
den jetzt anstehenden Winter zu kommen
einen kleinen Beitrag nicht mehr nicht
weniger
gleichwohl wäre es absolut fahrlässig in
dieser Situation auf diesem Beitrag
leichtfertig zu verzichten und mit dem
vorliegende 19 Gesetz zur Änderung des
Atomgesetzes dürfen drei Atomkraftwerke
in Deutschland über den
31.12.2022 hinaus bis spätestens zum 15
April 2023 Elektrizität erzeugen
meine Damen und Herren der Ihnen
vorliegende Gesetzentwurf Nacht
andererseits aber auch absolut deutlich
es muss beim Atomausstieg bleiben
Atomenergie ist und bleibt gefährlich
und ja nichts ist ohne Risiko aber bei
Atomkraft werden die Folgen eines
Unfalls oder gar eines Angriffs so
unglaublich verheerend dass wir gerade
jetzt daraus müssen der Deutsche
Bundestag hat 2011 abgewogen und
beschlossen dass dieses Restrisiko der
Atomkraftnutzung noch bis zum
31.12.2022 vertretbar ist das waren eine
Bundesregierung geführt von cdu/csu und
FDP und die nötige Abwägung zwischen
Versorgungssicherheit der Bevölkerung
mit Energie und den Risiken für den
Schutz der körperlichen Unversehrtheit
unserer Bevölkerung ist gerade im
Vergleich zu diesem Ausstiegsbeschluss
von 2011 jetzt eigentlich viel klarer
Atomkraftwerke sind erstmals im Jahr
2022 zum Ziel eines Krieges geworden sie
werden beschossen sie werden besetzt sie
werden vom Stromnetz gekappt und wir
erleben Angriffe und Sabotageakte auf
die Energieinfrastruktur in Europa und
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
deshalb ist es natürlich absolut richtig
dass die Bundesregierung dass die
Koalition in ihrer Abwägung zu dem
Ergebnis kommt dass wir zwar drei
Kraftwerke noch einige Wochen länger
laufen lassen um möglichst sicher durch
den Winter zu kommen das aber vor allem
mit dieser Gesetzesnovelle klargestellt
wird dass es beim Atomausstieg in
Deutschland bleibt Punkt
und um das vorwegzunehmen es wäre
natürlich aus den genannten Gründen
absolut falsch die AKW einfach
weiterlaufen zu lassen auch nur über den
Winter 23 24 hinaus ein preisdämpfender
Aspekt bei einer Laufzeitverlängerung
wäre wenn überhaupt absolut überschaubar
bereits die technische Realisierbarkeit
zweifelhaft Fragen der Sicherheit ohne
sicherheitsrabatt kaum zu beantworten
grundlegende Aspekte der Haftung
grundlegende Aspekte der Rolle des
Staates müssen neu verhandelt werden und
nicht zuletzt haben die Betreiber ihre
Skepsis mehrfach zu Protokoll gegeben
und deshalb meine Damen und Herren von
der cdu/csu ihr werben für eine echte
Laufzeitverlängerung es wäre
glaubwürdiger wenn Sie nicht bereits vor
dem Beginn des Angriffskrieges Russlands
gegen die Ukraine genau diese Debatte
begonnen hätten vor dem Angriffskrieg
mit ihren atomträumen mit ihren
atomträumen Versuchen sie tatsächlich
eine Entscheidung die sie unter der von
Frau Merkel geführten Bundesregierung
getroffen haben und Teile von ihnen nie
verschmerzt haben jetzt in dieser
Situation wo unser Land vor einer Krise
steht vor einer potenziellen Krise steht
in dieser Situation diese Debatte jetzt
erneut anzuheizen nachdem sie uns
unserem Land und der Sicherheit in
unserem Land mit ihrer damaligen Abkehr
vom Atomausstieg und wenige Monate
später dem Ausstieg vom Ausstieg ein
Bärendienst erwiesen haben diesen
Schmerz jetzt noch zu verarbeiten in
dieser Krise ich halte das für
verantwortungslos
die Abhängigkeit Europas und der
gesamten Welt von russischem und
kasachischem uran ist nicht minder
ausgeprägt als die von Gas von der
Abhängigkeit russischer Atomtechnologie
ganz zu schweigen und wir sehen mit
Bedauern wie unsere osteuropäischen
Nachbarn versuchen müssen sich aus dem
Klammergriff von rossertum zu entbinden
und das ist Gründe hat dass die nukleare
Versorgung immer noch nicht vom
europäischen Sanktionsregime erfasst ist
all diese Gründe führen dazu die
Endlagerfrage kommt noch dazu dass wir
Generationen unserer Kinder Enkel
Ururenkel den Atommüll überlassen bisher
weltweit kein einziges Endlager in
Betrieb befindlich ist all diese
Probleme all diese völlig ungelösten
Fragen und vor allem eine notwendige
neue Sicherheitsbewertung von Atomkraft
nach dem Angriffskrieg Russlands der
Atomkraftwerke in der Ukraine mit
erfasst hast führen dazu wir bleiben
beim Atomausstieg atomkraft ist nicht
die Zukunft sondern die Vergangenheit
und deshalb bitte ich Sie um Zustimmung
zu diesem Gesetzentwurf vielen Dank
sagt Steffi Lemke ja die Grünen Minister
Steffi Lemke und Robert Habeck hatten
noch im März davon abgeraten die drei
akbs länger als geplant zu betreiben
dann hatte Robert Hack vorgeschlagen
eine
Reservebetrieb für die beiden
süddeutschen AKWs und dann gab es wegen
unterschiedliche Ansichten in der Ampel
eine Machtwort von Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz deswegen heute dieser
Gesetzentwurf sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerin mit ihrer Politik verspielen
sie das Vertrauen der Menschen in
unserem Land und das Thema Kernenergie
macht das ganz besonders deutlich warum
sage ich das dazu drei Punkte dazu drei
Punkte 1
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat zu Beginn
des Krieges gegen die Ukraine eine
ergebnisoffene Prüfung der Nutzung der
Kernenergie versprochen
die mehr von einer ergebnisoffenen und
ideologiefreien Prüfung nimmt Ihnen
spätestens nach den letzten Enthüllungen
keiner mehr ab Frau Ministerin
Frau Lemke und der Habeck hatten nie vor
das Potenzial unserer Kernkraftwerke in
einer Gesamtstrategie jetzt in der Krise
ja ich sage ganz bewusst jetzt in der
Krise für eine sichere und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung unseres Landes
wirklich mit einzubeziehen die Aspekte
was ist am besten für unser Klima was
ist am besten für die
Strompreisentwicklung waren doch gar
nicht wirklich Teil dieser Prüfung sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin das geht so
nicht aus meiner Sicht wäre eine
Entschuldigung bei den Menschen in
unserem Land jetzt angebracht
zweiter Punkt sie negieren weiterhin
hartnäckig die möglichen preisdämpfenden
Effekte einer weiterreichenden einer
weiterreichenden nicht nur dreieinhalb
Monate Laufzeit verringern Verlängerung
Frau Professor Veronika Grimm andere
Ökonomen auch der Energiekonzern EnBW
der von einem Grünen geführten von einer
grün geführten Landesregierung
kontrolliert wird sagen es eindeutig für
2024 ließe sich der Strompreis unter
bestimmten Voraussetzungen um bis zu 12
13 Prozent senken die Experten sagen wir
brauchen dringend auch
2023 und 2024 ein breiteres
Energieangebot um die Preissteigerungen
beim Strom zu dämpfen und die 0,8%
hervorsitzender des Umweltausschusses
die vorhin genannt wurden von den
Experten die beziehen sich nur auf die
dreieinhalb Monate ich rede von den zwei
Jahren die wir Grundlagen Frau Dr
Weißgerber gestatten sie eine
Zwischenbemerkung oder Zwischenfrage aus
der Fraktion DIE LINKE ich würde jetzt
gerne weiterfahren
mit einem streckbetrieb der drei derzeit
noch laufen im Kernkraftwerke für nur
dreieinhalb Monate erreichen sie
letztendlich viel zu wenig wir brauchen
stattdessen einen Weiterbetrieb bis
mindestens Ende 24 so wie wir es
vorschlagen und natürlich frische
Brennelemente Frau Lemke Frau Ministerin
sie sind Verbraucherschutzministerin
warum lassen sie die Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher so im Regen stehen und
nehmen diesen einfachen
preisdämpfungseffekt für die kommenden
Jahre nicht mit sie tun nicht das was
jetzt in der Krise ich betone jetzt in
der Krise ist kein Ausstieg aus dem
Ausstieg sieht betonen nicht das was
jetzt in der Krise angezeigt ist und
verspielen noch mehr Vertrauen das ist
nicht das was unser Land jetzt braucht
frau Ministerin
dritter Punkt mit ihrem Gesetzentwurf
suggerieren sie dass die Energiekrise
die stromkrise im April nächsten Jahres
beendet sein wird schön wäre es aber mit
großer Wahrscheinlichkeit wird das
genauso eben nicht kommen und es ist
eine irrführung der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wenn Herr Kubicki das geht an die
Adresse der FDP sagt dass es sich sicher
sei dass wir im Frühjahr nächsten Jahres
das Thema Kernenergie neu diskutieren
werden denn im Unterschied zum
streckbetrieb brauchen wir dann Ende
April 24 eben neue Brennelemente ohne
neue Brennelemente wird es im nächsten
Jahr einfach nicht weitergehend 23 und
wenn wir jetzt keine neuen Brennelemente
bestellen verschenken wir weitere sechs
Monate das heißt im Klartext
so wie sie das Gesetz jetzt konzipiert
haben ist das Thema Kernenergie im April
23 durch und zwar egal ob wir egal ob
wir im nächsten Jahr Engpässe haben oder
nicht das ist Murks meine Damen und
Herren das ist Politik ohne Weitsicht
was wäre die Lösung ganz einfach eine
Überprüfungsklausel um im Laufe des
nächsten Jahres zu entscheiden welche
kernkraftwerkskapazitäten angesichts der
versorgensicherheit und der
Strompreisentwicklung benötigt werden
haben sie dazu in ihrem Gesetzentwurf
ein entsprechende Klausel vorgesehen
seine Kollegen von Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der FDP natürlich nicht
unser Gesetzentwurf sieht eine solche
Überprüfungsklausel vor am Freitag haben
Sie die Chance diesem Gesetzentwurf
zuzustimmen ich fordere Sie auf beginnen
sie endlich mit einer pragmatischen der
Krise angemessenen und vor allen Dingen
weitsichtigen Politik unser Land braucht
weniger Ideologie und mehr
Verantwortungsbewusstsein nur so können
wir das Vertrauen der Menschen
zurückgewinnen vielen Dank
und in dem von hier Anja Weißgerber
vorgeschlagen
Gesetzentwurf der
cdu/csu-fraktion da fordert die Fraktion
nämlich eine Laufzeitverlängerung ist
mindestens 31 dezember
2024 über diesen Gesetzentwurf der wird
übrigens auch am Freitag abgestimmt
Jakob Blankenburg können wir jetzt für
die spd-präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir beraten hier jetzt
heute in erster Lesung über den von der
Ampelkoalition vorgelegten Gesetzentwurf
zur Änderung des Atomgesetzes dieser
sieht vor dass die drei Atomkraftwerke
Isa 2 in der kawestheim 2 und Emsland
erst am 15 April 2023 und nicht wie
ursprünglich geplant Ende dieses Jahres
vom Netz gehen die Koalition aus SPD
Grünen und FDP strebt also an
Atomkraftwerke dreieinhalb Monate länger
am Netz zu lassen als ursprünglich
geplant ein durchaus bemerkenswerter
Schritt ein Schritt der vor einem Jahr
für mich als frisch gewählte
Abgeordneter unter anderem für das
Wendland die Keimzelle des
anti-akkw-protests in Deutschland
vollkommen unverständlich gewesen wäre
zu lange musste im Wendland und in
vielen anderen Ecken Deutschlands auf
der Straße für den Atomausstieg gekämpft
werden genauso wie hier im Bundestag vor
allen Dingen auf der linken Seite des
Hauses
heute da stehe ich vor Ihnen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und sage es ist
richtig dass wir die Änderung des
Atomgesetzes auf den Weg bringen die
Situation im November 2022 unterscheidet
sich fundamental von der im November
2021 wir leben in Zeiten eines
abscheulichen angriffskriegs Russlands
auf die Ukraine Russland führt diesen
Krieg auf ukrainischen Boden gegen das
ukrainische Volk und Russland führt ein
Energie-
die Unterbrechung der russischen Erdgas
Lieferungen kommen zusammen mit einem
unzureichenden Ausbau der Windkraft und
der Stromnetze gerade in Süddeutschland
wir haben es in den Zwischenrufen dann
eben gerade zu Recht gehört und dem
Ausfall eines substanziellen Anteils der
französischen Kernkraftwerke
das hat die Lage auf den Energiemärkten
weiter verschärft diese angespannte
energieversorgungssituation ist der
Grund warum wir hier heute die Änderung
des Atomgesetzes diskutieren
der Stresstest der viel
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber hat gezeigt
dass wir im kommenden Winter im
schlimmsten nicht wiederhole im
schlimmsten Szenario temporäre regionale
Stromausfälle und keine Blackouts wie
immer wieder von dieser Seite des Hauses
glauben gemacht werden würde in
Deutschland nicht komplett ausschließen
können und das trotz der zahlreichen
Maßnahmen die bereits durch die
Bundesregierung getroffen wurden und
deshalb gehen wir nun diesen Schritt des
Weiterbetriebs der drei noch am Netz
befindlichen Atomkraftwerke für die
kommenden Wintermonate was der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion und mir besonders
dabei wichtig war dieser Weiterbetrieb
erfolgt als streikbetrieb es werden
keine neuen Brennstäbe gekauft
stattdessen
stattdessen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen werden die bereits in den AKW
genutzten Brennstäbe so neu konfiguriert
dass sie noch für einen etwas längeren
Zeitraum Energie liefern können wir
schöpfen die bereits bestehenden
Energiequellen also voll aus das ist das
was wir in der besonders angespannten
Energiesituation braucht
was wir mit dem Gesetzentwurf nicht tun
ist das was sie was die Opposition
fordert und was ja auch koalitionsintern
in den letzten Monaten intensiv
diskutiert wurde wir kündigen den
Atomausstieg nicht auf
hier wir halten fest liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen worum jahrzehntelang
gerungen wurde und was 2011 in diesem
Hohen Hause mit sehr breiter Mehrheit
beschlossen wurde übrigens auch aus
ihrer Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Weißgerber dem Ende der
hochrisikotechnologie Atomkraft das ist
wichtig denn das was 2011 galt gilt auch
heute elf Jahre später Punkt eins
Atomkraft ist für den Menschen nicht
beherrschbar und bringt gewaltige
Sicherheitsrisiken das haben wir 1986 in
Tschernobyl erlebt 2011 in Fukushima und
auch jetzt im Jahr 2022 mit den
gezielten Angriffen auf ukrainische
Atomkraftwerke wie das in saporizia
menschliches Versagen Naturkatastrophen
kriegerische Angriffe sie alle können zu
nuklearen Zwischenfällen von gewaltigem
Ausmaß führen und damit Menschenleben
zerstören und die Natur für Jahrzehnte
oder Jahrhunderte unwirtlich machen und
selbst wenn die Nutzung der Atomenergie
ohne Störfälle gelingt dann bleibt immer
noch Punkt 2 die Frage der sicheren
Endlagerung der hochradioaktiven
Hinterlassenschaften der der Atomenergie
die es weiter ungeklärt jeden Tag den
wir die Atomenergie weiter nutzen
produzieren wir mehr Abfälle von denen
wir heute nicht wissen wohin und das ist
eine gewaltige Bürde für die
nachkommenden Generation und
und
damit komme ich zu Punkt 3 Atomenergie
ist teuer und das auch wenn Sie uns das
als Vertreter in der Opposition immer
wieder etwas anderes glauben machen
wollen wir haben es eben gerade in der
fachanhörung in der in der Anhörung im
Umweltausschuss gehört Atomenergie ist
die teuerste der Energieform es ist
deutlich teurer als Strom aus den
erneuerbaren und allein die zwischen-
und Endlagerung das müssen Sie sich
bewusst machen allein die zwischen- und
Endlagerung der radioaktiven Abfälle
verschlingt mehr als eine Milliarde Euro
jedes Jahr
diese Punkte die haben wir 2011 die
haben 2011 den Ausschlag für die
politische Entscheidung gegen die
weitere Nutzung der Atomenergie gegeben
und mit dieser Entscheidung da wurde ein
gesellschaftlicher Konflikt befriedet
und es wurde die Basis für ein
strukturiertes Verfahren der
Endlagersuche geschaffen und an diesem
im Standortauswahlgesetz festgelegten
Verfahren da müssen wir weiter
festhalten statt immer wiederkehrende
Debatten um eine Renaissance der
Atomkraft Zweifel an der Glaubwürdigkeit
des atomenergies zu nähren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen
Sie uns einen Schlussstrich unter diese
Debatte ziehen genau das machen wir mit
dieser Änderung des Atomgesetzes sie
lenkt von den wirklich wichtigen Fragen
ab wir müssen jetzt unter Hochdruck am
Umbau unserer Energieversorgung hin zu
Unabhängigkeit und Nachhaltigkeit
arbeiten und Atomenergie ist dafür
definitiv nicht die Lösung wir brauchen
wir brauchen stattdessen mehr Strom und
Wärme aus erneuerbaren und wir brauchen
Übertragungsnetze damit der Strom auch
dahin gelangt wo er gebraucht wird
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam daran arbeiten
dass diese Vorhaben gelingen statt Zeit
mit der Debatten der Vergangenheit zu
verschwenden vielen Dank
Jakob Plattenburg war das er ist direkt
gewählte Abgeordnete im Wahlkreis für
Lüchow-Dannenberg der ja über Jahrzehnte
geprägt war durch Proteste gegen das ich
ehemals potenzielle geplante Atommüll
Endlager Gorleben
reiner Kraft jetzt für die AFD
ja sehr geehrte Präsidentin Werte
Kollegen im Ergebnis einer Abwägung von
Nutzen und Risiken ist eine
Laufzeitverlängerung der drei noch
bestehenden Atomkraftwerke auch
angesichts der aktuellen Gaskrise nicht
zu empfehlen Zitat Ende sorgetiertes
bmvo in seinem Prüfvermerk vom März und
selten lag eine Einschätzung so weit
neben der Realität wie diese
Offenbarungseid aus dem Hause von
Ministerin Landwirt
obwohl also der jetzige Gesetzesentwurf
in Sachen der drei weiterlaufenden
Kernkraftwerke das bmuv fachlich
komplett vorführt so ist er dennoch
energiepolitisch vollkommen unzureichend
um der energienotlage in der Sie dieses
Land befindet gerecht zu werden zu wenig
und zu spät das passt sehr gut das
bisherige Krisenmanagement der
Bundesregierung zusammen nur
scheibchenweise und unter enormem Druck
der Bürger und Unternehmen die am Ende
die Zeche der energiepolitischen
Inkompetenz der Regierung zu zahlen
haben werden ist diese Regierung des
Aussetzens gewillt den notwendigen
Realitäten ins Auge zu schauen
erstens dieses Land hat eine
Energieproblem und es ist nicht die
fragestrom oder Gas wie ist der Herr
Minister schon öfter gesagt hat es ist
sowohl Strom und Gas das uns fehlt und
am Thema Strom zweitens müssen wir das
tun Strom und Gas werden jetzt benötigt
das ist zweitens Strom Gas werden jetzt
benötigt doch Maßnahmen die kurzfristig
wirken und nicht in einer fernen
irgendwann absehbaren Zukunft
Ankündigungen zum verstärkten Ausbau und
zuverlässiger Wind und Solarenergie
sowie die Absicht irgendwann irgendwas
mit vielleicht masterstoff zu machen
sind bestenfalls Nebelkerzen in der
entscheidenden Frage wie wir durch
diesen und den nächsten Winter kommen
werden viel wahrscheinlicher ist es
allerdings dass wir hier bei Ressourcen
verschwenden die wir dann in diesen
beiden Bildern dringend benötigt hätten
und eine dieser verschwindeten
Ressourcen das sind die drei noch
laufenden Kernkraftwerke und sowohl die
Union als auch die AFD haben vollkommen
richtige Gesetzesentwürfe präsentiert
die sie noch mindestens zwei Jahre unter
Volllast eine Energieerzeugung in
Deutschland zu beteiligen voll
abgeschriebene Kraftwerke mit
geschätzten Gestehungskosten so um die 3
Cent die Kilowattstunde
und der Entwurf der Bundesregierung weil
sie gerade sagen Atome wir hatten gerade
die Anhörung sie waren ja lange nicht da
um diesen halbe bis eine Prozent mehr
kommt es am Ende überhaupt nicht drauf
an ja es kommt auf dieses Prozent nicht
mehr an denn Wurf der Bundesregierung
will nun diese vier Gigawatt an
zuverlässiger Leistung in die Reserve
verbannen und hofft gleichzeitig auf
gutes Wetter und einen warmen Winter
damit wir gut durch den Winter kommen
das muss man sich mal vorstellen die
Verlierer
die Verlierer dieses bossenspiels stehen
auch schon fest es sind die Stromkunden
und Steuerzahler um vier Prozent
mindestens könnte der Strompreis senken
wenn die Kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen
würden so dass renommierte Ifo-Institut
höre 20 genannt worden von der Kollegin
her aber recherchieren diese
Bundesregierung schon vier Prozent
niedrige Stromkosten ja es ist ja nur
Geld das Geld der Wähler und
Steuerzahler das ist Ihnen doch komplett
egal aber dafür dass deutsche Familien
vier Prozent weniger beim Strom bezahlen
da tritt kein grüner Minister vor seine
Leute vor seine Parteimitglieder und
räumt eine diese grünen Lebenslügen Weg
für vier Prozent niedrige Stromkosten
für kleine und mittlere Unternehmen
stellt sich kein FDP-Minister hin und
verzichte auf seine Privilegien oder
beendet diese irrlichternde
geisterfahrerkoalition
und vier Prozent reduzierte Stromkosten
sind auch bei der SPD nichts um die SPD
aus ihrem Flecken aufzuwachen hauptsache
die Koalition hält bis 2025 und wenn man
dazu in der Frage der Kernkraft die
Wähler allen voran diejenigen diejenigen
Niedersachsen anlügen muss komplett
anlügen muss komplett egal
dass die Koalition in dieser Frage
falsch liegt zeigt ein Blick in die
Nachbarländer ja kennen die gefeiert
Renaissance allen Unkenrufen zum Trotz
polen will einsteigen Frankreich und
Schweden verkündigen Bauern neuer
Kraftwerke Belgien verschiebt erneut den
Ausstieg die Liste der Nutzer ist lang
und alle haben sie etwas gemeinsam sie
sorgen für preiswer und zuverlässige
Stromversorgung ihrer Länder und damit
machen diese Länder Energie sich
energiezuberennen und Koppeln sich auch
von auch von den unzuverlässigen
Stromversorgung Deutschlands ab und weil
diese Länder in Zukunft Strom
zuverlässig haben werden sie dann auch
mit sattem Gewinn in Deutschland mit
Strom versorgen können und dazu sage ich
Gott sei Dank denn hier regiert eine mit
dem Thema Energieversorgung komplett
überfordert die Bundesregierung die eben
das nicht kann
nächste Rednerin für die FDP-Fraktion
Carina Konrad und sie ist die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzender
der Liberalen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jede
Kilowattstunde zählt mit diesem
Botschaft mit diesem Appell hat sich der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister im Juni an die
Menschen gewandt und dieser
einsparappell der ist auch bis heute
richtig jeder Beitrag zur Bewältigung
der Krise macht einen Unterschied der
völkerrechtswidrige Angriff Russlands
auf die Ukraine ist auch zu einem
energiekrieg geworden gegen Europa und
er hat uns auch besonders stark
getroffen erhöht das Fundament auf auf
dass wir alle gebaut haben in den
letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten und
dieses Sabotage von Frieden von Freiheit
und von Wohlstand die darf Putin nicht
gelingen und wir kämpfen hier Tag für
Tag dafür damit sie Putin nicht gelingt
haben wir wirklich schon alles getan
diese Frage stelle ich mir jeden Tag neu
und die Menschen überprüfen sich auch
alle jeden Tag sie sparen Energie und
leisten entscheidende Beiträge das ist
anstrengend das ist auch unbequem ich
habe mit einer Familie gesprochen die
haben den ganzen Oktober nicht geheizt
bei uns im Mittelgebirge in
Rheinland-Pfalz war das schon manchmal
nachts ganz schön kalt so ein Verzicht
der ist unbequem aber er ist machbar und
tagtäglich senden aber Unternehmen
unterschiedlichster Branchen jetzt
Notrufe an uns Stellenabbau
Produktionseinschränkungen
produktionsabbau sogar die Standortfrage
wird immer öfter offen gestellt Menschen
und Unternehmen sind angesichts der
enormen finanziellen Herausforderungen
überlastet diese Krise geht an unsere
Substanz und wir tragen als Parlament
die Verantwortung dafür in dieser
schwierigen Zeit die richtigen Antworten
zu finden und das tun wir wir können
entlassen und das haben wir mit drei
entlastungspaketen getan doch wir können
diese Krise nicht Komplex
subventionieren das funktioniert nicht
wir müssen auch die Energieversorgung
sichern eine sichere eine saubere und
eine bezahlbare Versorgung mit Energie
ist überlebensnotwendig für Menschen und
für Wirtschaft in unserem Land und dafür
ändern wir in dieser Woche auch das
Atomgesetz das ist eine Frage der
Vernunft diese Entscheidung ist
unumgänglich geworden und mit der
Laufzeitverlängerung der drei sicheren
und der dreiklimaneutralen
Kernkraftwerke Isa 2 Emsland und
Neckarwestheim 2 wird die
Stromversorgung über den Winter
stabilisiert und natürlich war der Weg
bis hierhin nicht einfach wer hätte denn
ernsthaft im letzten Jahr gedacht dass
es eine Ampel ist die die
Laufzeitverlängerung von drei
Kernkraftwerken beschließt und ich bin
dankbar dass unsere Koalitionspartner
diesen Weg mit uns gehen und ich bin
auch Olaf Scholz dankbar für seinen Mut
den Menschen in unserem Land mit seiner
Entscheidung Stabilität zu geben denn
wir haben nicht nur einen Stress bei den
Kraftwerken durchgeführt machen wir uns
ehrlich der energiestresstest wurde in
diesem wurde für diesen Winter
durchgeführt und er hat gezeigt dass uns
Netz Engpässe und schwierige
versorgungssituationen bevorstehen
können um das zu verhindern ist diese
Entscheidung diese Laufzeitverlängerung
richtig doch diese Krise ist auch ein
Stresstest für unsere Gesellschaft viele
Menschen müssen die Komfortzone
verlassen und die erwarten zu Recht dass
auch die Politik alle notwendigen
Entscheidungen trifft um das
Energieangebot zu sichern und
auszudehnen und die Reaktionen übrigens
bei Gas- und Strompreisen aktuell zeigen
uns dass wir auf dem richtigen Weg sind
mit den Maßnahmen die wir ergreifen und
das ist ein zentrales Signal zu
Entspannung und auch deshalb ist diese
Entscheidung die wir heute treffen
richtig
und auch Europa
Stress diese Energiekrise wir sind
eingebunden in den europäischen
Energiemarkt und da hilft man sich
gegenseitig und da ist man auch
voneinander abhängig und jedes Land muss
deshalb auch seinen Beitrag dazu leisten
Energie zu sichern und Netze zu
entlasten und auch deshalb ist diese
Laufzeitverlängerung richtig und mit der
Verlängerung dieser Laufzeiten
entspannen wir die Energiesituation für
diesen Winter wir entlasten die
angespannte Gesellschaft und wir
entspannen auch unsere Beziehungen zu
den europäischen Nachbarn doch nach
diesem Winter und da haben sie ja recht
kommt garantiert wieder ein Winter und
man muss kein Prophet sein um auch heute
schon sagen zu können dass die Frage der
Energieversorgung auch dann zentral sein
muss und deshalb müssen auch heute schon
alle notwendigen Maßnahmen eingeleitet
werden um über den nächsten Winter
hinaus die richtigen Antworten zu geben
und ich kann Ihnen für die FDP-Fraktion
versprechen dass wir dabei weiter
genauso konstruktiv wie bisher aber auch
genauso deutlich sein werden wie bisher
einiger Wohlstandsverlust und eine
nachhaltige Destabilisierung unserer
wirtschaftlichen Grundlage und unseres
Zusammenlebens in Sicherheit und
Freiheit steht auf dem Spiel und das ist
genau das Ziel was Putin doch verfolgt
und dieses Ziel darf er nicht erreichen
und wir Freien Demokraten wir werden
nicht zulassen dass das Fundament
unseres Zusammenlebens ausgehöhlt wird
wir müssen diesen Stresstest hier wohl
oder übel gemeinsam bestehen und dafür
werden wir gemeinsam miteinander ringen
und wir werden auch weiter streiten doch
am Ende müssen Entscheidungen getroffen
werden denn unsere Aufgabe ist es
Frieden Freiheit und Wohlstand zu
beschützen und das heute und auch für
die Zukunft unser gesellschaftliches und
unser wirtschaftliches Fundament ist auf
eine sichere auf eine saubere und auch
auf eine bezahlbare Energieversorgung
gebaut und dieses Fundament braucht
Stabilität und dafür zählt jede
Kilowattstunde und deshalb bitte ich um
breite Zustimmung in dieser Woche zu
diesem Gesetz vielen Dank
Carina Konrad für die FDP auch wenn Ihre
Fraktion sich hätte noch längere
Laufzeiten vorstellen können und eine
zentrale Forderung der FDP war ja
ursprünglich auch die Beschaffung neuer
Brennstäbe das soll es aber nach diesem
hier gelesenen Gesetz nicht geben
liebe Zuhörerinnen Zuhörer letzte Woche
trat in Frankreich aus dem Leck eines
Reaktors Radioaktivität aus zum Glück
gibt die Radioaktivität im
Reaktorgebäude dieser Reaktor ist 34
Jahre alt und schon versagt das Material
wer denkt dies wäre ein Einzelfall den
muss ich enttäuschen in Frankreich sind
zurzeit etwa die Hälfte der 56
Atomreaktoren wegen ähnlichen
Materialproblemen außer Betrieb
die deutschen Atomkraftwerke haben das
gleiche Alter
seit Monaten weise ich Sie auf die
Probleme mit Atomkraftwerken hin lege
ihn die realen Gefahren von
Atomkraftwerken da das können Sie in
mein Reden nachverfolgen aber sie die
atomkraft-lobby ist in der Ampel der
Union und der AFD blenden die unangenehm
Wahrheit zu Atomkraft aus und dies würde
zu jeder Abwägung gehören müssen
ihre Hauptbegründung für eine
Laufzeitverlängerung ist
Energieknappheit in diesem Winter im
Frühjahr sah es auch danach aus aber
durch die wieder in Betriebnahme von
Kohlekraftwerken im Herbst ist die
Energieversorgung technisch
sichergestellt
um eines klarzustellen ist ärgert mich
das vorübergehend Kohlekraftwerke wieder
laufen müssen aber in dieser Situation
ist mir Kohlestrom lieber als mit den
riesigen der Atomkraft leben zu müssen
die Koalition begründet ihre
Entscheidung mit dem Stresstest der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber aber wir haben
kein erzeugungsproblem in der
Stromversorgung sondern ein politisches
Problem
künstlicher Wettbewerb mit
sternregularien und Börsenspekulationen
drängen uns den Atomstrom auf wenn ich
wiederhole es bewusst noch einmal wir
brauchen keinen Atomstrom um durch den
Winter zu kommen es wäre eigentlich ganz
einfach
teilen Sie Deutschland in zwei
stromhandelspreiszonen dann dürfen die
süddeutschen Kraftwerke ständig Strom
liefern auch bei vier Windkraft im
Norden werden sie dann nicht aus
regulatorischen Gründen abgeschaltet um
es Ihnen noch mal klar zu erläutern die
Mangellage in Deutschland besteht nicht
wenn wenig Wind liegt weht die mangelage
besteht wenn in Norddeutschland viel
Wind ist und dann natürlich der Strom
nicht nach Bayern geliefert werden kann
und in Bayern aber wegen des zu vielen
Windstroms im Norden Gas und Ko
Handwerker abgeschaltet werden solch
einen Schwachsinn zu an solch einem
Schwachsinn festzuhalten ist falsch und
dann die Atomkraftwerke als Ersatz in
die parkschale zu werfen ist der völlig
falsche Weg und das lehnen wir als LINKE
ab und im übrigen wenn Sie diesen
Vorschlag der Strompreis der
stromhandelszonentrennung folgen dann
brauchen Sie auch nicht 16 Milliarden
Euro zu bezahlen für die Mehrkosten die
ausgelöst wurden durch die einheitliche
strompreiszone die Laufzeitverlängerung
löst keine Probleme sondern schafft neue
vielen Dank
sagt Ralf lenkert für die Linke so
nächster Redner wird sein Helmut Klebern
für die SPD-Fraktion erst der
Vorsitzende des Beirates für nachhaltige
Entwicklung
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit einigen
Monaten diskutieren wir den
Weiterbetrieb die Laufzeitverlängerung
der Atomkraftwerke ich will noch mal
kurz die Ursachen für diese Debatte
aufzählen es ist in erster Linie der
angriffskriegs Krieg Russlands auf die
Ukraine es ist mit Sicherheit ein
zweiter Stelle das ausbleibende Gas aus
Russland wohlgemerkt kein embargo
sondern das einseitige Abdrehen der
Gaslieferung durch Putin es ist der
fehlende Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien im Süden unserer Republik durch
die bayerische Landesregierung ebenso
wie quasi der Boykott des Netzausbaus
mindestens genauso wichtig wie der
fehlende Windkraftausbau und es ist
natürlich auch auch das wurde schon
gesagt
der Ausfall der Atomkraftwerke in
Frankreich an dieser Stelle
International wurde hier gesprochen von
einer Renaissance der AKW wir hatten
gerade in der Anhörung einen
interessantes Ergebnis
international betrachtet ist gerade das
Gegenteil der Fall weil der
internationale Kraftwerkspark der AKW
schneller arbeiten schneller altert als
die Ausbaupläne der betreffenden Staaten
vorhanden sind das heißt es passiert de
facto ein schleichender Ausstieg aus der
Atomenergie statt einer Renaissance also
das komplette Gegenteil
positiv am vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf
ist aus meiner Sicht auf jeden Fall dass
es sich eben gerade nicht um eine
Notreserve handelt sondern es handelt
sich um einen regulären geregelten
absehbaren steuerbaren vorbereitbaren
streckbetrieb und eben nicht in
irgendeiner Konstellation gehen wir mal
schnell mit ein paar AKW ans Netz das
kann ich funktionieren insofern völlig
richtig dass wir das hier so machen
Ausgangspunkt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen weil der hier schon mehrfach
angesprochene zweite Stresstest und es
ist eben nicht so Herr lenkert dass
alles hundert Prozent gesichert ist
sondern der Test hat eindeutig ergeben
dass es ein gewisses wenn auch kleines
für ein paar Stunden mit einer gewissen
Leistung versehen des Risiko gibt und es
ist auch klar dass die Atomkraftwerke
die wir in den streckbetrieb geben
werden dieses Risiko leider nur zum Teil
auffangen werden also es ist ein Risiko
ich persönlich bin überzeugt dass es
nicht greifen wird weil eben unsere
anderen Maßnahmen auch zum Tragen kommen
der Preiseffekt über den geredet worden
ist auch das hat die Anhörung gegeben
ist ergeben ist höchst spekulativ die
Spannbreite die da berechnet worden ist
je nachdem welches Szenario angenommen
worden ist zeigt aber eines der
preisseffekt den wir damit erzielen
würde nämlich insbesondere auch mit
einem Betrieb bis Ende 24 ist so gering
dass er weit hinter dem zurückbleibt was
wir eine entlastungspaketen geschnürt
haben weit hinter dem zurückbleibt was
mit der strompreisbremse erreicht werden
wird und insofern ist es völlig richtig
diesen Weg den sie vorschlagen nicht zu
gehen
es ist klar der streckbetrieb der
Atomkraftwerke ist nur ein Baustein um
für eine Energiesicherheit in diesem
Winter zu kommen sind einige Dinge
genannt ich will nur nennen die
Gasspeicher sind zu fast 100 Prozent
gefüllt übrigens der höchste Füllstand
in den letzten Jahren erreicht obwohl
Putin seinen Gashand zugedreht hat
wir werden weiter Gas einsparen die
Preissignale die Gesetz sind werden
trotz der Preis Bremsen erhalten bleiben
auch das ist ein wichtiger Punkt und zum
Jahresende werden die schwimmenden
lng-terminals am Netz sein und uns
unterstützen wir werden eben die Kraft
wärmekopplung bei den Gaskraftwerken
eben nicht abschalten können wir werden
weiterhin auch Gas verstromen und das
ist ein wichtiges Signal wir haben eine
Fülle von Maßnahmen und wir werden in
diesem Winter Energie sicher sein
noch ein Wort zum längerfristigen
Weiterbetrieb den Sie vorschlagen ich
bin wirklich sehr erstaunt also bis 2024
ist da die Idee aber das Entscheidende
ist ja ihr Hintertürchen und dass man
muss man hier ganz klar benennen diese
prüfoption ist ein ganz klares
Hintertürchen und ich zähle jetzt mal
auf für den Ausstieg vom Ausstieg des
Ausstiegs aus dem Ausstieg also selten
so eine Kapriole gesehen die sie hier
schießen und die ist mit uns nicht zu
machen
noch ein Wort zum Thema Abhängigkeiten
Brennstäbe Brennelemente Uranförderung
wir würden uns auf diesem Weg in
dieselbe Abhängigkeit von Russland
begeben wie wir beim Gas in 50 Prozent
der weltweiten Förderung sind in
Russlands Hand entweder direkt oder
mittelbar das heißt dieses preisspiel
die Verunsicherung der Märkte die Putin
mit uns beim Gas gespielt hat kann er
könnte er würde er an dieser Stelle
wieder genauso spielen auch wenn die
Kondition ein klein wenig anders sind
ist mir bewusst aber wir dürfen an
dieser Stelle dieses Risiko auf keinen
Fall eingehen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ein Wort vielleicht noch nein kein Wort
mehr ich bitte um Zustimmung zu dem
Gesetzentwurf danke schön
wahrscheinlich weil die Redezeit
abgelaufen war Helmut Klebern war das
für die SPD-Fraktion ja er hat
angesprochen es gab heute durchaus
interessante
parlamentarische Beratung in den
Ausschüssen auch schon es gab eine
Expertenanhörung im Umweltausschuss zu
dem Thema und es gab heute morgen eine
öffentliche Sitzung des
Petitionsausschusses wo es um eine
Petition ging die sich für eine
Laufzeitverlängerung ausspricht also das
spielt natürlich heute hier in diese
Debatte auch immer wieder hinein Klaus
Wiener jetzt für die cdu/csu-fraktion
an aber der Preis dafür war hoch
gefrecktes Gas wurde teuer eingekauft
aber was noch viel schlimmer ist in dem
Zusammenhang sie haben ärmeren Ländern
das Gas auf den Weltmärkten vor der Nase
weggeschnappt die Aufregung hierüber ist
groß zu Recht wenn man bedenkt was das
für die Menschen dort oftmals an
existenzieller not bedeutet
nicht minder groß
nicht minder groß ist die Aufregung
darüber dass in der aktuellen mangelage
alte Kohlekraftwerke zum Einsatz
gebracht werden während die viel
klimafreundlichere alternative Atomstrom
von ihnen ausgeklammert wird bis ja bis
auf den kläglichen streckbetrieb über
den wir heute in erster Lesung beraten
viele aus ihrem Lager sagen immer wieder
gebetsmühlenartig das sei eine
hochrisikotechnologie darüber meine ich
lässt sich streiten zumindest wird das
im Ausland ganz überwiegend nicht so
gesehen und man findet den Begriff auch
gar nicht in der wissenschaftlichen
Literatur sicher ist aber sicher ist
aber das mit Blick auf das Klima eine
hoch das sie inzwischen eine
hochrisikopolitik betreiben und wenn sie
mir schon nicht glauben dann zitiere ich
hier nochmal an der Stelle Herrn
rockström vom Potsdam Institut für
Klimafolgenforschung am Wochenende in
der fast nachzulesen die Klimakrise ist
viel zu ernst und bestehende Kraftwerke
zu schließen nur sie wollen es einfach
nicht verstehen nur sie wollen es
einfach nicht verstehen
Entschuldigung Herr Dr Wiener gestatten
sie eine Zwischenbemerkung oder Frage
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
nein ich würde hier einfach weitermachen
der Einsatz der Kernkraftwerke würde im
Vergleich zu Strom aus Kohle die Mission
um jährlich 70 Millionen Tonnen CO2
verringern das muss man sich mal auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen 70 Millionen
Tonnen CO2 das sind knapp zehn Prozent
aller unsere Missionen oder 40 Prozent
der Emissionen die wir einsparen müssen
wenn wir die 2030er Ziele Pariser
Klimaziele einhalten wollen Deutschland
wird seine CO2-Ziele in den nächsten
Jahren krachen verfehlen und dafür
tragen sie die Verantwortung
jetzt höre ich sehr guter Hinweis Herr
Ebner sehr guter Hinweis jetzt höre ich
aus ihrem Lager immer wieder hätte
Deutschland die erneuerbaren Energien
stärker ausgebaut hätten wir das
Energieproblem nicht das ist das muss
man mal so deutlich sagen blanker Unsinn
zum einen weil Deutschland
zum einen weil Deutschland die
erneuerbaren Energien deutlich stärker
ausgebaut hat als fast alle anderen
Länder auf dieser Erde das habe ich hier
an dieser Stelle auch schon wieder rot
ausgeführt noch schlimmer aber ist dass
die die Dimension des Problems verkennen
von 600 Terawatt Strom Stunden Strom die
wir jährlich bauen brauchen kommen 300
Terawattstunden aktuell aus den
Erneuerbaren das sind 50 Prozent ein
schöner Erfolg der letzten 16 Jahre über
den ich mich wirklich freue
unser jährlicher Energiebedarf beträgt
den toto aber nicht 600 Terawattstunden
sondern 3.400 Terawattstunden also mehr
als das 11-fache verstehen Sie mich
nicht falsch auch ich will dass die
Erneuerbaren ausgebaut werden und das
mit Tempo aber seien Sie doch endlich
mal ehrlich zu den Menschen ja das wird
Zeit brauchen viel Zeit und auch
entscheiterndes möglich ja weil
geldtechnologien Fachkräfte fehlen
deshalb wäre es klug vielleicht mal
zuhören deshalb wäre es klug alle
Energieformen so lange zu nutzen bis wir
wissen dass wir es geschafft haben und
nicht vorher abschalten in dieser
dramatischen Situationen beraten wir
heute in erster Lesung ein Atomgesetz
das ein Weiterbetrieb nur bis zum 15
April vorsieht aber nicht mit neuen
Brennstäben was sinnvoll wäre sondern im
dürftigen streckbetrieb ich habe es ja
schon gesagt und das auch nicht aus
tieferer Einsicht heraus sondern weil
der Kanzler mit einem Last Minute
Machtwort den Koalitionsfrieden retten
musste ich war im Sommer mit dem
Umweltausschuss in Schweden Herr Ebner
sie waren ja auch dabei auch da will man
aus der Kernenergie aussteigen das macht
man aber mit einem gewissen Pragmatismus
nämlich man steigt erst da aus wenn die
Erneuerbaren hinreichend ausgebaut sind
das würde ich mir auch für Deutschland
wünschen aber das würde erfordern dass
sie einen klaren Plan haben wie wir die
Energiewende unter den dramatisch
geänderten Rahmenbedingungen tatsächlich
hinbekommen das liegt aber bislang
leider nicht vor und es würde erfordern
und es wird erfordern dass sie ihre
Verantwortung endlich gerecht werden und
wirklich alle Optionen auf den Tisch
bringen dazu gehört in der aktuellen
Krise eben auch ein Weiterbetrieb der
bestehenden Kernkraftwerke über den 15.4
hinaus kein Wiedereinstieg wohlgemerkt
aber schon so dass es für die Menschen
und die Unternehmen einen Unterschied
macht das ist in ihrem Gesetz nicht der
Fall und deswegen lehnen wir diesen
Gesetzentwurf auch ab vielen Dank
und sagt Klaus Wiener für die
cdu/csu-fraktion aber heute wird ja noch
nicht abgestimmt erste Lesung und
deswegen gehe ich jetzt nach Klaus
Wiener der war ja der letzte Redner für
heute dieser Gesetzentwurf in die
Ausschüsse wir hören mal die
Bundestagspräsidentin in der
Tagesordnung aufgeführten Ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen ich sehe keine weiteren
Vorschläge dann ist das so der Fall dann
genau und am Freitag wird es dann hier
im Bundestag in zweiter und dritter
Lesung beraten und mutmaßlich dann
verabschiedet mit den Stimmen der
Ampelkoalition also mit diesem mit
dieser Änderung des Atomgesetzes bleibt
es bei der Grundsatzentscheidung aus der
Kernenergie auszusteigen auch wenn die
drei verbliebenen AKWs dann bis Mitte
April 2023 laufen können bei Isa 2 zum
Beispiel wird es wahrscheinlich nicht
der Fall sein weil die Brennstäbe
voraussichtlich nur bis zum März reichen
so wir bleiben beim Thema und gehen
nahtlos rüber in die Befragung der
Bundesregierung mit Steffi Lemke sehr
frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen und
Kollegen das Bundeskabinett hat sich
heute unter anderem mit der gegenwärtig
in Ägypten stattfindenden Konferenz zum
Schutz des globalen Klimas befasst und
in diesem Sinne die Maßnahmen die
Beiträge mit der auch Deutschland auf
der klimakopf vertreten ist besprochen
klar ist dass diese klimakopp in einer
international extrem schwierigen
Situationen stattfindet die
Verhandlungen natürlich ebenfalls durch
den Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine belastet sind und wir alle daran
arbeiten dass die Kopp dennoch unter
diesen schwierigen Umständen zu einem
Erfolg werden wird die klimakopf steht
in enger Verbindung zur auch noch in
diesem Jahr in Montreal im Dezember
stattfindenden
weltnaturschutzkonferenz der sogenannten
bio-diff-cop das heißt auch dort wird es
das zweite Mal noch in diesem Jahr auf
internationaler Ebene um gute Abschlüsse
um gute Verhandlungen für den Schutz
unserer natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen in
Deutschland in Europa und global
das Bundesprogramm natürlicher
Klimaschutz dass sich als
Bundesministerin aufgelegt habe
adressiert beide Krisen die Klimakrise
und die naturkrise das Arten aussterben
das heißt mit diesem Programm wollen wir
Ökosysteme so renaturieren dass sie
Kohlenstoff einspeichern können ein
positiven Beitrag für den Wasserhaushalt
leisten und außerdem die Natur die
biologische Vielfalt schützen und als
ein Bestandteil dieses Aktionsprogramms
natürlicher Klimaschutz habe ich heute
die moorschutzstrategie im Kabinett
eingebracht die auch verabschiedet wurde
Moore sind gegenwärtig in Deutschland
für 7,5 Prozent der CO2-Emissionen
verantwortlich das ist glaube ich so gar
nicht unbedingt bekannt aber ein
wirklich relevanter Beitrag für die
klimaschädlichen Gase und deshalb werden
wir mit der moorschutzstrategie die
immer die Kommunen die Landnutzer dabei
unterstützen einerseits die wenigen noch
vorhandenen Moore zu schützen also keine
weiteren Moore zu zerstören und zu
entwässern und zweitens Moore wieder zu
vernetzen den Wasserstand etwas
anzuheben oder stark anzuheben um
einerseits zu verhindern dass weiter
Kohlendioxid ausgast aus diesen [ __ ]
und idealerweise Kohlenstoff sogar
wieder eingelagert werden kann das ist
eine Win-Win-Situation wir machen das im
kooperativen verfahren wir haben mit dem
Aktionsprogramm natürlicher Klimaschutz
das erste Mal jetzt auch Geld zur
Verfügung um die Landnutzer bei den
Nutzungsänderungen zu unterstützen und
von daher möchte ich mich bei allen
Beteiligten Ressourcen herzlich bedanken
für die äußerst konstruktive und
angenehme Zusammenarbeit an der
moorsturz-strategie ich möchte noch
einen weiteren Punkt erwähnen in diesem
zusammenh wir haben heute ja gleich noch
die Diskussion die
Gedenkveranstaltung zum programmgedenken
aber der 9 November heute Nacht jährt
sich auch zum 33 mal das Symbol für die
friedliche Revolution 1989 der Fall der
Mauer und was mir wichtig ist an diesem
Tag ist dem Beitrag den auch Umwelt und
Naturschützer in der ehemaligen DDR für
die friedliche Revolution geleistet
haben zu würdigen auch das ist glaube
ich wenig bekannt dass es eine äußerst
engagierte Umwelt- und
Naturschutzbewegung gegeben hat die
schweren Repressalien ausgesetzt war
Akten über die Daten über die Umwelt
waren in der DDR Geheimsache sie durften
nicht publiziert werden und dennoch hat
es viele Menschen gegeben die sich für
saubere Luft gegen den Frauen
kohletagebau für gesunde Flüsse
eingesetzt haben und dieser wirklich
große Frage Bestandteil der
Bürgerrechtsbewegung der friedlichen
Revolution wir sind ihm zu tiefem Dank
verpflichtet denn wir verdanken ihm
einerseits das nationalparkprogramm das
in der Wendezeit begonnen wurde und wo
engagierte Umweltschützer Michael Soko
sei hier stellvertretend genannt und
seine Mitstreiter es quasi in einer
Nacht und Nebelaktion geschafft haben
eine relevante Fläche wertvolle
Naturschutzflächen in der ehemaligen DDR
damals unter Schutz zu stellen das
sogenannte Tafelsilber der deutschen
Einheit und wir daraus abgeleitet heute
Nationalparke Naturreservate
Biosphärenreservate in der gesamten
Republik haben und dieser Impuls aus der
Wendezeit heraus aus der
ddr-naturschutzbewegung heraus jetzt
überall in unserem Land zu spüren ist
das möchte ich an diesem Tag ganz
explizit würdigen ich glaube unser Dank
führt all diesen Menschen und das ist
unsere Verantwortung im doppelten Sinne
das nationale Naturerbe am Leben zu
erhalten für unsere Kinder und Enkel und
für unsere Demokratie vielen Dank
zum Auftakt der Befragen der
Bundesregierung die einleitenden Worte
von Steffi Lemke ist dürfen rund eine
Stunde die Abgeordneten Fragen zu dem
Ressort Umwelt Naturschutz für nukleare
Sicherheit und Verbraucherschutz die
Fragen sind vorher nicht bekannt Frau
Steffi Lemke und zum Geschäftsbereich
sowie zu den vorangegangenen
Kabinettssitzung und mit allgemeinen
Fragen zuerst hat das Wort
der Kollege Steffen Bilger aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion
ja vielen Dank Frau Ministerin für Ihre
Ausführungen ich muss aber noch mal
Bezug nehmen auf ihre Rede von gerade
eben zum Atomgesetz denn da haben sie ja
sich auf vieles bezogen sie haben aber
nichts gesagt zum sogenannten
Prüfvermerk vom 7 März aktuelle
medienrecherchen bestätigen unseren
Vorwurf dass es sich bei diesem
sogenannten prüfermerk zum Weiterbetrieb
von Atomkraftwerken eben nicht um eine
fachlich unvoreingenommene Prüfung
gehandelt hat sondern letztendlich um
eine politische Auftragsarbeit zurzeit
läuft er sogar noch eine Klage auf
Herausgabe von Akten gegen das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium aber die
recherchierten Journalisten konnten
bereits Unterlagen aus ihrem Haus dazu
einsehen und die belegen eben diesen
Vorwurf dass der prüfermarkt politisch
und nicht fachlich so erstellt wurde ich
frage Sie ganz konkret Frau Ministerin
warum haben die Auswirkungen auf den
Klimaschutz beim Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke im Prüfer mehr keine
Rolle gespielt warum haben die
Auswirkungen auf den auf die
Strompreisentwicklung mit dem
Weiterbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke im
Prüfer mehr keine Rolle gespielt sie
kamen zum Ergebnis der Weiterbetrieb sei
wieder nötig noch sinnvoll waren das
politische Vorgaben ganz konkret haben
sie die Öffentlichkeit hier getäuscht
Frau Ministerin
Abgeordneter diese Vorwürfe weise ich
auf das entschiedenste zurück und ich
glaube dass wir
ich glaube dass wir es der Bevölkerung
in dieser Krisensituation wirklich
schuldig sind die Regierungsfraktion
aber auch die Oppositionsfraktionen
seriös und ernsthaft und sachlich unsere
Probleme hier zu diskutieren
ich habe in meinem Haus bereits Anfang
des Jahres um Informationen zu einer
potenziellen zu einem potenziellen
Weiterbetrieb von Atomkraftwerken
erbeten weil im öffentlichen Raum die
Debatte um die Verlängerung von
Laufzeiten begonnen hatte bevor der
Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine begonnen hatte ihr
Fraktionsvorsitzender Herr Merz wurde am
11 februar in einem Artikel des
redaktionsnetzwerkes Deutschland unter
der Überschrift behandelt strahlende
Zukunft Fragezeichen das stenkt hinter
den Atomkraft träumen von Friedrich Merz
das heißt dass ihr Konstrukt dass sie
die Laufzeitverlängerung ausschließlich
wegen des Angriffskrieges Russlands
gegen die Ukraine zur Krisenbewältigung
fordern ist falsch diese Diskussion
wurde bereits vorher von Ihnen im
politischen im öffentlichen Raum
begonnen und deshalb habe ich ebenfalls
bereits Anfang des Jahres begonnen mir
Informationen aus meiner Fachabteilung
zu zu lassen unter welchen Bedingungen
so etwas stattfinden könnte überhaupt
bzw natürlich was dagegen spricht das
ist meine verdammte Pflicht und
Schuldigkeit abzuwägen was wären die
Bedingungen und was spreche dagegen und
ich glaube da besser auf die Zeit Frau
Ministerin vielen Dank ich hatte die Uhr
bisher noch nicht im Blick frau
Präsidentin sie fingen jetzt erst an zu
leuchten
vielleicht darf ich noch eine zweite
Anmerkung hinterher schieben ich spar
die Zeit später wieder ein ich glaube
das ist notwendig ist in der
Öffentlichkeit noch mal transparent zu
machen dass mein Ministerium für
nukleare Sicherheit zuständig ist und
das Wirtschaftsministerium für die
Energieversorgung und das genau diese
beiden Aspekte Energiesicherheit und
nukleare Sicherheit Miteinander von uns
wirklich Wochen und monatelang
öffentlich und transparent abgewogen
worden sind
Herr beger sie können eine Nachfrage
stellen jetzt nur noch im 30
Sekundentakt bei der Nachfrage 30 und
auch für die Antworten nur 30 okay wir
können ja vielleicht meine fragezeit
außer auslegen wie die Antwort Zeit
gerade eben aber nun gut Frau Ministerin
sie haben eine Frage nicht wirklich
beantwortet ich will noch mal konkret
Nachfassen sie haben unter anderem in
der Antwort auf eine kleine Anfrage
unserer Fraktion vom 14 April angegeben
ich zitiere der Prüfvermerk wurde auf
der Grundlage von Gesprächen mit den
Betreibern der Kernkraftwerke erstellt
nun wissen wir aber durch die
Medienrecherche dass die EnBW in bereits
am zweiten märz schriftlich mitgeteilt
hat also wenige Tage vor
Veröffentlichung ihres prüfvermerks dass
der Weiterbetrieb für die
Versorgungssicherheit sinnvoll und für
eine preisdämpfung erforderlich sei wir
reden hier immerhin um einen Strompreis
der je nach Studie bis zu 14 Prozent
höher sein wird ohne die
Laufzeitverlängerung und wir wissen auch
dass die von ihren eigenen Experten
berichten der Einsparung an
Treibhausgasen bei einem Weiterbetrieb
als ab 2024 etwa 25 bis 30 Millionen
Tonnen weniger CO2 pro Jahr aus einem
Entwurf des prüfvermerks gestrichen
wurde auch hier konkrete Frage haben Sie
oder jemand anderes aus der politischen
Leitung ihrer beiden Häuser diese
Streichung veranlasst
Herr Wilger ich weise den Vorwurf dass
hier irgendwas intransparent
ausgehandelt wurden oder vertuscht
worden wäre erneut zurück wenn irgendein
Thema in der Öffentlichkeit in den
letzten neun Monaten in unserem Land
absolut transparent und absolut
öffentlich auch kontrovers ausgetragen
worden ist dann ist es die Diskussion um
die Frage von Laufzeitverlängerung das
konnten sie alles nachlesen sie haben
den enbw-vermerk eben selber zitiert und
natürlich sind all diese Informationen
es ist eine Vielzahl von Informationen
gewesen verschiedenster Seite
verschiedene Gespräche mit verschiedenen
Betreibern auch mit der Atomaufsicht der
Länder dann in der Schlussphase all das
ist in die Abwägung der Bundesregierung
eingeflossen und hat dazu geführt dass
wir sagen eine kurzzeitige
Laufzeitverlängerung ja jetzt um
Energiesicherheit herzustellen in diesem
Winter eine Neubeschaffung von
Brennelementen und jahrelange
Laufzeitverlängerung nein genau das ist
der Abwägungsprozess gewesen
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsident Frau
Ministerin bleibe beim Thema oder muss
ich ja sowieso welche Nachfrage Stelle
es ist erstaunlich dass der Minister
habe hier dafür gerade den Ärger kriegt
denn die Reaktorsicherheitskommission
unter ihrem Haus dem bmuv und die Welt
zitiert jetzt Personen aus dem aus der
rektor-sicherheitskommission also einer
Behörde die ihnen untersteht die sagen
dass das Gremium von dem Ministerien den
Plural also von beiden Ministerium am
imprüfermarkt des Mertes nicht
konsultiert worden ist Frau Ministerin
deswegen eine ganz einfache Frage haben
Sie dass die RSK Direktor
Sicherheitskommission konsultiert und
sind die Antworten des rsks am Ende in
dem Prüfbericht eingeflossen vom März
vielen Dank Frau Minister
auch dazu der Abgeordneter sage ich noch
mal all diese Dinge liegen ebenfalls
öffentlich und transparent auf dem Tisch
auch die Kritik aus der
Reaktorsicherheitskommission heraus
wurde ja öffentlich von einem Mitglied
vorgetragen und wir haben alle
zuständigen Institutionen in meinem Haus
und in den nachgeordneten Behörden in
unserer Abwägung mit einbezogen in ihren
jeweiligen Funktionen die eben
unterschiedlich sind und
selbstverständlich habe ich mir
persönlich und hat sich mein Haus die
notwendige Beratung für den
Abwägungsprozess herangeholt alles
andere wäre vollkommen fahrlässig genau
um diese Abwägung seriös zu treffen
haben wir sehr früh mit dem Betreibern
gesprochen das ist doch ein Ausweis
dessen dass wir mit dem Betreibern
zusammen bereits im März das Gespräch
geführt haben gesucht haben dass wir
auch die Expertise der Betreiber selbst
in unserer Abwägung mit einbeziehen
wollten und das ist dennoch kontrovers
ist weil auch nukleare Sicherheit
abgewogen werden musste unter dem
Eindruck des Krieges in Russland des
Beschusses von sapörrisch ja all das
haben wir monatelang getan mit dem
entsprechenden Ergebnis
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin mein Wahlkreis liegt
direkt zwischen zwei
Kernkraftwerken wir haben einmal den
Forschungsreaktor in Garching und einmal
den Landshuter das Landshuter Kraftwerk
Kraftwerke sind und das muss dem letzten
seit dem Krieg auch aufgefallen seit
auch Angriffsziele während Kugeln um das
krafting saporicia Fliegen sind auch wir
Ziel von Angriffen und meine Frage an
Sie ist wie ist die Bewertung der
aktuellen Sicherheitslage und wie können
wir den Schutz unserer Kernkraftwerke
auch hier in Deutschland verstärken um
sie von möglichen Angriffen zu schützen
vor Sabotage oder Unfällen
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter sie
beschreiben richtig dass wir eine
komplett veränderte Sicherheitslage für
die auch zivile Atomkraftnutzung ganz in
ganz Europa und weltweit haben durch den
Angriffskrieg Russlands wo
Atomkraftwerke beschossen worden sind
okkupiert worden sind vom Stromnetz
getrennt worden sind und das
selbstverständlich zu einer veränderten
Sicherheitsbewertung führen muss deshalb
haben wir einerseits sowohl über die
Internationale Atomenergieorganisation
sofort Kontakt aufgenommen und
beobachten fortlaufend die Situation
Umsatz für regia und auch ursprünglich
Tschernobyl herum wir haben dort den
ständigen Kontakt wir haben natürlich
das messstellennetz in Deutschland
überprüft und dort die entsprechenden
Maßnahmen eingeleitet wir haben ja ein
hervorragendes Messstellen Netz in
Deutschland dass eine potenzielle
Belastung sofort erkennen würde
Strahlenbelastung sofort erkennen würde
und es gibt eine Vielzahl von weiter
Maßnahmen die wir diesbezüglich
überprüft oder ergriffen haben aber es
ändert nichts daran dass das Restrisiko
der Atomkraftnutzung eben bestehen
bleibt und dass wir gemeinsam als
Gesetzgeber in dieser Woche die
Entscheidung treffen ob wir verantworten
dass dieses Restrisiko noch dreieinhalb
Monate länger von uns in Kauf genommen
wird aufgrund der
energieversorgungssituation
Frau Weißgerber
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin sie
verzichten also auf die klimafreundliche
Kernenergie deswegen verwundert es auch
nicht dass aus dem prüfermerk die
möglichen Einsparungen bezüglich der
CO2-Reduktion gestrichen wurden das
wurde nämlich auch im Rahmen der
Recherche der Medien bekannt und da sie
auf die klimafreundliche Kernenergie
verzichten verwundert ist auch nicht
dass sie in den Eckpunkten zum
Klimaschutz Sofortprogramm auch auf die
sektorziele verzichten und sie deutlich
aufweichen wir haben diese extra auch
als daumenstrauben und als
Kontrollmechanismus eingeführt was ist
das für ein Signal an die Klimakonferenz
diese Frage Frau Weißgerber hätte ich
gerne von Ihnen beantwortet weil ich
stehe hier als Ministerin die an die
geltende Gesetzeslage gebunden ist und
die geltende heute geltende Gesetzeslage
heißt dass die Atomkraftwerke zum 31.12
diesen Jahres abgeschaltet werden müssen
und nach meiner Kenntnis ist diese
Gesetzeslage von einer Koalition aus
cdu/csu und FDP herbeigeführt worden das
heißt wenn sie danach fragen ob es
verantwortbar ist auch unter
Klimaschutzgründen aus der Atomkraft
auszusteigen so haben cdu/csu und FDP
das mit einem glasklaren ja beantwortet
das finde ich eigentlich gut
weil ich persönlich Atomkraft nach wie
vor für soriskanthalter dass ich auch in
der Abwägung mit Klimaschutzgründen der
Meinung bin wir sollten die Nutzung von
Atomkraft nicht fortsetzen und sie
müssen ja erläutern warum sich jetzt
Ihre Bewertung seit 2011 verändert hat
und warum sie jetzt nachdem halt auch zu
lange nicht in die erneuerbaren Energien
investiert worden ist warum sie dann
jetzt sagen jetzt 2011 ging es aus
klimaschutzgrund mit dem Ausstieg aber
jetzt geht es aus Klimaschutzgründen
nicht mehr mit dem Ausstieg ich glaube
die Erklärung müssten sie dann noch in
ihre Frage mit einflechten
[Applaus]
in Frau Ministerin
mir kommt jetzt gerade diese Frage der
der Risiken der Atomkraft zu kurz wir
sehen wenn wir nach Frankreich schauen
dass der ein Großteil des des Kraftwerk
Parks in Frankreich stillgelegt ist aus
Sicherheitsgründen dort wurden Risse
entdeckt wo sie nicht erwartet waren und
für mich erstaunlich im Nachhinein wird
gesagt es sei ja erklärbar dass es da
stattgefunden hat wir sehen also an der
Stelle das im Bereich einer
hochrisikotechnologie ein Learning bei
doing stattfindet was mich ehrlich
gesagt
schockiert wie würden Sie denn in dieser
Hinsicht in dieser vor dieser Lage die
Debatte um den Laufzeitverlängerung und
vor allem um die Sicherheit von
Atomanlagen bewerten
vielen Dank ich glaube dass die
Situation in Frankreich ja vor allem
auch unter
energieversorgungsaspekten für unsere
französischen Partner im Moment extrem
schwierig ist weil eben aus
Wartungsgründen aus Sicherheitsgründen
rund die Hälfte der französischen AKWs
jetzt seit vielen vielen Monaten vom
Netz ist und das deshalb wegen der
intensiven Atomkraftnutzung dort ein
Strom und ein Preisproblem gibt wir sind
natürlich auch hier im Austausch über
die Fragen der Sicherheit von
französischen Atomkraftwerken
insbesondere was die Grenzregionen zu
Deutschland anbetrifft und ich verlasse
mich selbstverständlich wenn ich eine
solche Gesetzesnovelle hier heute in den
Deutschen Bundestag einbringe dass die
Betreiber der deutschen AKWs und die
Atomaufsicht der jeweils zuständigen
Bundesländer wirklich Tag und Nacht und
zu jeder Stunde die Sicherheit unserer
Atomkraftwerke gewährleisten können
ansonsten wäre der Betrieb nicht
verantwortbar aber ich habe im Moment
Zweifel dass das gewährleistet wird von
Betreibern und Atomaufsicht der Länder
und dann natürlich auch von der obersten
Atomaufsicht sprich meinem Hause
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin für die
Möglichkeit hier auch noch mal zu diesem
hochkomplexen Thema und dieser
hochrisikotechnologie Ihnen eine Frage
stellen zu dürfen sie als Haus das Haus
hat ja jetzt in dieser Sitzung ein sehr
besonnenen Antrag eingebracht einen
besonderen Gesetzentwurf dass wir für
wenige Monate in einen streikbetrieb
gehen das sehen andere Teile des Hauses
anders
als wäre meine Frage sie sind ja in
regelmäßigen Gesprächen mit den
Energieversorgungsunternehmen mit den
Betreiberinnen und Betreibern der drei
noch am Netz befindlichen Atomkraftwerke
und aus deren sich so ist zumindest auch
aus Medienberichterstattung zu hören
haben die auch gar kein Interesse daran
über einen möglichen streckbetrieb
hinaus das wirtschaftliche Risiko dafür
zu tragen sondern fordern stattdessen
dass der Bund in eine quasi-eignerschaft
übertreibt und der Bund betreibt wäre
das aus ihrer Sicht aus Sicht des bmuv
überhaupt rechtlich möglich und wie
bewerten Sie diese Forderung der vor uns
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter vielleicht
darf ich präzisieren dass mein Haus dass
ich persönlich nicht in regelmäßigem
Austausch mit den Betreibern stehen weil
die Fragen der Energieversorgung und
Energiesicherheit im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium angesiedelt
sind das heißt der Austausch dort ist
wesentlich enger wir haben jetzt im Zuge
der Diskussion über potenzielle
streckbetrieb oder Reservebetrieb
ebenfalls direkte Gespräche mit dem
Betreibern gehabt ja auch mit der Folge
dass dann die Diskussion über die
ventilleckage öffentlich geworden ist
aber der engere Austausch findet auf
bmwk-seite statt nichtsdestotrotz hielte
ich eine Haftungsübernahme für den
Betrieb von Atomkraftwerken weder
rechtlich verantwortlich noch politisch
verantwortlich noch sicherheitstechnisch
verantwortlich das kann und das muss ich
ausschließen wir haben auch über solche
Fragen mit den Betreibern
zwischenzeitlich diskutiert und die
Bundesregierung ist defin intensiv der
Auffassung dass dies kein Weg wäre
dann komme ich jetzt wieder zurück zu
den angemeldeten Fragen und da hat Frau
Dr Seidel die nächste
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin das
Artensterben ist die zweite globale
Krise neben der Klimakrise die wir
derzeit erleben der Verlust der
Biodiversität ist hierzulande aber auch
weltweit dramatisch im September
Entschuldigung im Dezember soll in
Monreal die 15 weltnaturkonferenz die
Top 15 stattfinden wir wünschen uns
einen Paris Moment für den Artenschutz
für klare deutliche Ziele und auch für
messbare Indikatoren wie wahrscheinlich
schätzen sie ein dass es einen solchen
ein solches anspruchsvolles
Rahmenabkommen für den Artenschutz geben
wird
vielen Dank für die Frage und an dieser
Stelle auch den Dank an das ganze Haus
für die ja immerwährende und große
Unterstützung für die Frage des Arten
Aussterbens die zweite große ökologische
Krise und auch die Unterstützung dafür
dass es auch in diesen Zeiten nicht aus
dem Blick gerät dass wir diese Krise
haben ich gehe davon aus dass es möglich
sein wird ein neues globales Rahmenwerk
zu verabschieden und das 30 mal 30 Ziel
also 30 Prozent der Fläche an Land und
an mehr unter Schutz zu stellen auch
tatsächlich umzusetzen sicher ist es
nicht die klimakop zeigt gerade wie
schwierig die geopolitische Situation
ist die Verhandlungen schließen
natürlich auch Russland schließen China
schließen die Vereinigten Staaten die
nicht cbd-mitglied sind aber dennoch ja
ein bei der klimakop sowieso und es ist
schwierig in diesen Zeiten solche
Abkommen zu erreichen deshalb arbeiten
wir quasi Tag und Nacht in unserem Haus
und ja mit Ihrer Unterstützung daran die
europäische Verhandlungsposition so
auszurichten dass es möglich sein wird
und ich bin sehr dankbar dass
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz bei der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen auch die Finanzzusage von 1,5
Milliarden Euro für die internationale
biodiversitätsunterstützung zugesagt hat
das ist gutes Reisegepäck für schwierige
Verhandlungen ich hoffe dass es ein
Erfolg wird
haben sie eine Nachfrage bitteschön sie
haben gerade die Finanzzusage des
Bundeskanzlers Olaf Scholz genannt die
vorsieht eine Verdoppelung des deutschen
Beitrags für den Schutz der
Artenvielfalt weltweit auf 1,5
Milliarden ab 2025 durchzusetzen sehen
Sie die Bereitschaft anderer
EU-Mitgliedstaaten
ähnlich ambitioniert
Finanzierungszusagen für die Top 15 zu
machen
wenn mein Sachstand noch aktuell ist das
verändert sich ja gerade täglich oder
stündlich dann gibt es in diesem Umfang
noch keine weiteren Finanzzusagen ich
gehe aber davon aus dass diese kommen
werden noch bis zur Korb weil wir auch
in einer heimischen koralischen
zusammenarbeiten mehrere Staaten die
sich hier zusammengeschlossen haben um
Rückenwind zu geben für die biotive Cop
und nicht nur Industriestaaten sondern
auch Schwellenländer mit einzubeziehen
in diese heimischen Collection und es
ist ein wirklich intensiver und
großartiger Arbeitsprozess man merkt das
ist sehr viele Menschen umtreibt global
unsere Natur unsere natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen schützen zu wollen und
von daher setze ich darauf dass diese
Finanzzusagen noch kommen werden wir
werden in Ägypten nächste Woche ich
werde selber zur klimakopp Reisen auch
ein Treffen dort haben dass die biotive
vorbereiten soll ich will eine Brücke
zwischen diesen beiden internationalen
großen Konferenzen schlagen und ich
hoffe dass wir nächste Woche spätestens
auch bei den finanz den nächsten Schritt
haben werden
Herr Dr Hoffmann bitte
Frau Ministerin zunächst mal herzlichen
Dank an die Bundesregierung dass der
Kanzler auf der Klimakonferenz noch eine
Milliarde für Wald und
Biodiversitätsschutz draufgelegt hat
herzlichen Dank auch für ihre
moorinitiative das dient sowohl dem
Klimaschutz als auch dem Artenschutz auf
der anderen Seite höre ich dass sie dem
International Council for game and
wildlife conservation nicht mehr
angehören wollen als Deutschland und den
Austritt aus dieser Organisation die
sich verdient gemacht hat um Artenschutz
zum Beispiel das Nashorn wieder
geschützt hat und auch wieder gebracht
hat ist das wirklich der Ernst dass sie
da austreten wollen aus dieser
Organisation zweitens ist es gibt es
dazu einen Kabinettsbeschluss oder wie
wir das in der Regierung behandelt und
drittens weil die Frage ob wir damit
nicht vorschubleisten einer Art
neokolonialen Politik dass wir den
Ländern dort vorschreiben wollen wie sie
mit ihren natürlichen Ressourcen umgehen
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter ich gehe
davon aus dass sie auf die Gespräche im
Rahmen der dritten großen
internationalen Konferenz die am 14
november starten wird der Zeit des
Konferenz abzielen wo es ja zwischen
Umweltorganisationen und zwischen
verschiedenen afrikanischen Staaten eine
kontroverse Debatte darüber gibt wie der
Schutz verschiedener stark gefährdeter
Tierarten am besten zu gewährleisten ist
und wir haben uns zu dieser Diskussion
noch keine abschließende Meinung
gebildet sie haben wahrscheinlich
gesehen dass es da ziemlich hoch her
geht gerade und ich teile Ihr Anliegen
dass wir gerade aus Europa heraus auch
aus Deutschland heraus nicht den
Eindruck erwecken dürften wir wissen es
besser als die afrikanischen Staaten wie
es geht aber andererseits sind wir seit
vielen Jahren wahnsinnig engagiert im
Naturschutz als Bundesrepublik in den
afrikanischen Staaten diese Balance
werden wir in den nächsten Tagen
herstellen müssen
uns in dieser schwierigen auch
diplomatisch schwierigen Situationen
positionieren ich bitte Sie um
Verständnis wenn ich dazu jetzt keine
weiteren Details ausführen kann
sie haben jetzt gerade viel von
Atemschutz gesagt auch vom Moorschutz
ganz am Anfang eingeleitet wir haben
einen Bereich in Deutschland wo wir eine
Menge an geschützten Arten haben das ist
das Wattenmeer ich komme aus Friesland
und jetzt plant man im Wattenmeer mit
dem lng-terminal am Zulauf vom Jadebusen
180 Quadratkilometer Wattenmeer dort
regelmäßig mit Chlor und anderen
Chemikalien zu verseuchen dort soll 0,2
Mikrogramm Chlor pro Liter eingeleitet
werden direkt im Zulauf des kompletten
jadebosens im Wilhelmshaven am LNG
Terminal soll das eingeleitet werden und
sozusagen alle zwölf Stunden wird dann
der Jadebusen dort mit Chlor
desinfiziert das ist selbst Juniper
selbst sagt die Betreiber Firma dass es
zehnfach über den Grenzwerten was machen
sie um zu verhindern dass wir hier
diesen chloreinsatz haben und das
Wattenmeer entsprechend als
Naturschutzgebiet unterstützt wird
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordnete auch für
diese Frage des illustriert glaube ich
noch mal eindrucksvoll wie wichtig der
Schutz unserer Umwelt einerseits ist und
warum es auch Gründe gegeben hat dass in
der Vergangenheit keine lng-terminals
gebaut worden sind was wir jetzt gemacht
haben um die Energiekrise das ist ja ein
Anliegen aller Fraktionen dieses Hauses
in diesem Winter und auch in der Zukunft
im Griff zu behalten ist
planungsbeschleunigung für die
Errichtung von lng-terminals die
Beschleunigung in den Verfahren
ermöglichen aber keine standardabsenkung
in den Schutzstandards das heißt es gibt
da wieder einen Freibrief noch
erleichterte Rahmenbedingungen in den
Schutz Standards und von daher habe ich
die Informationen aus der Presse die
ihnen vermutlicherweise auch jetzt Ihrer
Frage zugrunde liegen entnommen und wir
gehen dieser Sache nach aber es gibt
keine Erlaubnis auch nicht mit der
beschleunigten uvp-prüfung dort
Standards abzusenken
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin und vor
allem vielen Dank dafür dass sie in den
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten immer
wieder auf die Relevanz der
un-biodiversitätskonferenz hingewiesen
haben das ist ganz wichtig und dass die
Bundesregierung auch in allen globalen
gesprächsformaten beispielsweise in der
Umweltgruppe der G7 auch die Relevanz
des biodiversitätsschutzes verankert hat
weil es geht in der Tat um nichts
weniger als eben um dieses globale Netz
der Arten und Ökosysteme das unsere
Lebensgrundlage ist dass uns versorgt
mit einem was wir zum Überleben brauchen
und das im übrigen auch ein ganz
wichtigen Beitrag zum Klimaschutz
leistet es hat ja die EU abgestimmt auf
dem umweltministerrat jetzt das
Verhandlungsmandat auf den Weg gebracht
mich würde einmal interessieren wie
bewerten sie das Verhandlungsmandat und
was sind aus ihrer Sicht die wichtigsten
Punkte und die wichtigsten Ziele für die
Konferenz in Montreal
vielen Dank das Verhandlungsmandat der
EU betrachte ich als ein sehr starkes
und sehr gutes Verhandlungsmandat wir
haben uns ja auch hier in den
vergangenen Monaten als
Bundesumweltministerium sehr stark
eingebracht und vielleicht darf ich an
dieser Stelle auch meinem Haus einmal
Dank dafür sagen das sind wirklich
intensive Arbeiten die ja parallel zur
akuten Krisenbewältigung dennoch
stattfinden die wichtigste
Zielvereinbarung des 30x30 Ziel der neue
globale Rahmen hatte ich bereits
angesprochen ich bin zuversichtlich dass
wir dieses erreichen werden aber
eigentlich brauchen wir ja noch mehr und
auch das Paris Momentum ist ja jetzt
schon ein paar Jahre alt so dass wir
eigentlich bereits darüber hinweg sein
müssen und deshalb habe ich mich
persönlich sehr stark dafür eingebracht
dass die Ziele auch umsetzbar und
kontrollierbar sein müssen das heißt
dass wir nicht nur Ziele für in fünf
oder zehn Jahren verabschieden sondern
tatsächlich ins Handeln kommen dafür
brauchen wir dann auch die
internationale
biodiversitätsfinanzierung und die
Kontrollierbarkeit von solchen
Zielvereinbarungen und ein
Anpassungsmechanismus falls Ziele nicht
erreicht werden und Sie merken an den
Ausführungen das sind wirklich
ehrgeizige globale Verhandlungsziele die
wir haben und ich freue mich mit der
EU-Kommission ein wirklich starken und
versierten Verhandlungspartner in
Montreal an meiner Seite zu haben
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin leider
sieht man sie nicht von den 103
süßwasserfischarten in Deutschland sind
55% vom Aussterben bedroht und weitere
10% erzählarten sind bereits
ausgestorben ich frage sie was
unternimmt die Bundesregierung zum
Schutz unser einheimischen Fischarten
welche Maßnahmen ergreifen Sie und
werden Sie sich in der Europäischen
Union dafür einsetzen dass es ähnlich
wie zur europäischen
Vogelschutzrichtlinie eine europäische
fischschutzrichtlinie geben wird
vielen Dank Kollege lenkert der
Hauptbeitrag meines Hauses in dieser
Legislaturperiode wird das
Aktionsprogramm natürlicher Klimaschutz
sein mit dem wir auch genau auf dem
Wasserhaushalt aber auch auf
Fließgewässer und auf Seen abzielen das
heißt hier nicht nur den Schutz
verbessern wollen sondern auch
renaturieren wollen Sie und ich haben ja
viele Jahre in der Parlamentariergruppe
frei fließende Flüsse zusammengearbeitet
von daher kennen sie meinen Engagement
in diesem Bereich ich hoffe dass die
Parlamentariergruppe ja ihr Leben ihre
Arbeit fortsetzt es war ein wichtiger
Treiber und wir werden jetzt das erste
Mal wirklich Geld zur Hand haben um
nicht nur die haarfarenaturierung
vorzusetzen sondern auch in anderen
Bereichen Auen und Fließgewässer die
besonders bedroht sind zu schützen und
ich persönlich habe mich auch dafür
eingesetzt dass wir Bauwerke der kleinen
Wasserkraft das heißt sie nur ein
minimalen Energieerzeugung haben also
kein Beitrag zur Energie in relevanten
Umfang leisten aber möglicherweise
Fließgewässer negativ beeinträchtigen
dass wir dort die Förderung nicht
fortsetzen und ich hoffe dass wir auch
da in Zukunft mit dem Betreibern oder
den erichtern in ein Umbauprogramm
eintreten können weil das gerade für
kleine Fließgewässer an vielen Stellen
ein großer ökologischer Fortschritt wäre
ohne Verlust für die Energiewende
Herr grau
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin vielen Dank
für die Möglichkeit hier Fragen zu
können es gibt eine Reihe von
wissenschaftliche Hinweise dafür dass
der massive atemschwund und die
Verarmung einzelner biotrophe was den
Artenreichtum angeht die Gefahr für
Zoonosen deutlich erhöht also für
Krankheiten die von Tieren auf die
Menschen übertragen werden wie jetzt
gerade die corona-pandemie wie sehen Sie
die Bedeutung der Biodiversität und des
Artenschutzes für die menschliche
Gesundheit insgesamt und für den Schutz
vor Infektionskrankheiten insbesondere
und welche politischen Maßnahmen leiten
sich daraus ab vielen Dank
ich sehe die Bedrohung durch Zoonosen
für die menschliche Gesundheit als
extrem an wir leben gerade noch mit
Corona also einer Zoonose und die
Wissenschaft sagt uns dass wir uns
darauf einstellen müssen dass solche
übersprünge von Viren von würztieren auf
den Menschen und sich dann auch das
weitere Fortsetzen der Erkrankung von
Mensch zu Mensch dass wir zumindest das
Risiko haben dass so etwas häufiger
auftreten kann in Zukunft und wir wissen
auch aus der Wissenschaft dass es ein
Zusammenhang gibt zwischen der
Vernichtung von Naturräumen und der
Erhöhung dieses Risikos das heißt auf
desto geringerem Raum Wildtiere sich
zusammenziehen sich zurückziehen müssen
desto weniger ausbreitungsraum Sie haben
desto größer wird das Risiko solcher
zionosen von Wildtieren auf den Menschen
und deshalb ist Naturschutz auch ein
Beitrag zum zur losen Schutz ich will
nicht so weit gehen zu sagen dass wir
damit alle Probleme in den Griff
bekommen würden um Gottes Willen aber
weitere naturraumvernichtung erhöht das
Risiko und auch deshalb brauchen wir
Naturschutz brauchen wir Artenschutz und
wir haben auf internationaler Ebene mit
dem Global Health Trust fand ein
Instrument gestartet um auch dieses
Thema stärker in die Öffentlichkeit zu
bringen ich glaube hier gibt es noch
große Wissenslücken in unserer
Gesellschaft auch wir alle hier im
Parlament haben glaube ich bei Corona
eine steile Lernkurve diesbezüglich
gehabt und wir auch unterstützen können
finanziell
Herz Brantner
die Frau Lemke sie haben erwähnt dass
sie in der kommenden Woche zur
Weltklimakonferenz nach Sharm el Sheikh
Reisen
Weltklimakonferenzen einem idyllischen
Touristenort in Ägypten 30.000
Teilnehmer über 30.000 Teilnehmer die
wenigsten werden mit dem Fahrrad oder zu
Fuß CO2 neutralanreisen daher meine
Frage wie reisen sie nach Sharm
el-Sheikh und zu welcher CO2-Ausstoß ist
damit verbunden und auf die
Bundesregierung bezogen wer von der
Bundesregierung reißt wie nach Schleim
el Sheikh und welche CO2-Emissionen
haben wir allein aufgrund dieser
Reisetätigkeit zur Weltklimakonferenz zu
erwarten
Herr Brandner ich habe keine
Zugverbindung nach Sharm el-Sheikh
gefunden ich reise aber
ich reise aber in meinem Alltag sehr
häufig mit dem Zug und ich tue das auch
gerne ich glaube mindestens wöchentlich
auch mit Maske unter den Bedingungen die
wir mit Corona immer noch haben und wenn
Ihre Frage darauf abzielt ob solche
Konferenzen Sinn ergeben trotz des
CO2-Ausstoßes der damit verbunden ist
unbestritten damit verbunden ist ja
diese Konferenzen ergeben dennoch sind
auch wenn Sie ein negativen klimabeitrag
in der kurzfristperspektive haben weil
es im Moment unser einziges Instrument
ist um globale Klimaschutz
Vereinbarungen zu erreichen und gerade
ihre Fraktion versucht ja Klimaschutz
auch damit zu diskreditieren dass es
nichts bringen würde wenn wir ihn nur in
Deutschland betreiben würden das ist
insoweit richtig ich glaube sie meinen
das anders als ich aber wir brauchen die
internationale Verständigung auf
Klimaschutz wenn die Menschheit
überleben will und deshalb müssen wir
auch miteinander reden muss man sich
miteinander treffen ich lade Sie
herzlich ein auch einmal eine solche
Konferenz zu besuchen und sich mit denen
Staaten die jetzt vom steigenden
Meeresspiegel betroffen sind wo bereits
jetzt ernten vernichtet worden wo
Pakistan von einer verheerenden flutheim
gesucht wurde direkt mit den Menschen
dort vor Ort zu sprechen die sich für
Klimaschutz engagieren ich glaube es ist
auf jeden Fall eine Erfahrung zurück
vielen Dank ja verehrte Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer heute ist im politischen
Berlin der Terminkalender tatsächlich
dicht gedrängt während hier der
Bundestag debattiert wollen wir trotzdem
einen Blick werfen auf ein anderes
wichtiges Ereignis denn heute legen die
Wirtschaftsweisen in Berlin ihr
jahresgutachtens vor also wir entwickelt
sich die deutsche Wirtschaft im
kommenden Jahr und das passiert in der
Bundespressekonferenz dahin wollen wir
kurz schalten Mädels dann hier wieder um
16 Uhr
können wir das Thema breiter in die
Öffentlichkeit bringen gestellt und ich
finde den one health Ansatz ganz
spannend wo wir dann sozusagen auch noch
mal in den Blick nehmen was ich
herauswirkungen hat der Verlust der
Artenvielfalt eben auch auf die
Gesundheit des Menschen und deswegen
meine Frage an Sie sie werden ja auch
nach maurial fahren ist es ihren
Kenntnisstand
dass sie dort auch in diesen Dimensionen
diskutiert wird das würde mich
tatsächlich sehr interessieren vielen
Dank
wir werden das Thema von globaler
Gesundheit auf jeden Fall auch auf der
biotive adressieren ich habe mein
konkretes Veranstaltungsprogramm für den
Dezember noch nicht vorliegen welche
bilateralen Gespräche ich jeweils führen
werde aber dort wo ich spreche werde ich
diesen Ansatz auf jeden Fall auch weiter
verfolgen und natürlich spielt es auch
jetzt auf der klimakopp eine große Rolle
wir haben gerade jetzt aktuelle
Prognosen wie Hitzewellen in Zukunft in
Europa auch
Todesursache verstärkt sein wird also
die Hitzewellen die Klimaveränderungen
auch hier die menschliche Gesundheit
gerade von vulnerablen Gruppen also
älteren Menschen kleinen Kindern die
schlechter auf Hitze reagieren können
und die häufig davon massiv betroffen
sind das heißt wie wir da Vorsorge
tragen können ein Thema und sie wissen
ja glaube ich auch dass bei mir im
Ressort mit
klimaanpassungsmaßnahmen in sozial
Einrichtungen genau diese Vorsorge
unterstützt wird indem wir Hitzeschutz
sei es in Altenheimen Pflegeheimen oder
in Kitas finanziell unterstützen können
und dass uns hier Entschuldigung und
hier noch eine große Aufgabe bevorsteht
so ich habe jetzt noch
drei Kollegen die Nachfragen hier zu
stellen wollen dann gehe ich weiter zu
den angemeldeten Fragen und dazwischen
teile ich Ihnen noch etwas Trauriges mit
jetzt ist erstmal Herr von der Weg dran
ja Frau Ministerin
erstmal vielen Dank für die ganzen
Informationen Biodiversität finde ich
auch großartig insofern finde ich passt
diese Frage auch noch in diesen
Zusammenhang der Deutsche Bundestag hat
in der letzten Sitzungswoche halt mit
wirklich beeindruckender einstimmiger
Mehrheit beschlossen dass wettelmeer zu
schützen in der letzten Woche ist eine
sehr negative Entscheidung gefallen
international und ich würde mich
wirklich dafür interessieren von ihnen
mal zu hören ob es wenigstens Bewegung
gibt bei den beiden die dort immer
blocken also Russland und China also
gibt es in den Gesprächen irgendwas zu
berichten was uns Hoffnung machen kann
für die nächsten Jahre
zu meinem großen Bedauern liegen mir
solche Erkenntnisse im Moment nicht vor
und ich hatte ja sowohl bei der klimakop
als auch bei der biotive Kopf darauf
hingewiesen wie schwer gegenwärtig für
globalen Fortschritt die geopolitische
Situation ist und Sie haben die beiden
hauptplayer angesprochen es wird
unglaublich schwer sein gerade in diesen
Zeiten wo ja auch fischfanggründe noch
brutaler ausgeblendet werden an
verschiedenen Stellen unserer Welt eine
solche schutzvereinbarung hinzubekommen
das ist die negative der negative Teil
der Nachricht der positive ist dass wir
ja bis auf diese beiden Player
inzwischen wirklich breiten Rückenwind
haben auch Staaten gewinnen konnten die
anfangs diesen schutzantrag nicht
unterstellt haben und ich habe
persönlich mit der klimabeauftragten der
Bundesregierung Frau Jennifer morgen
über dieses Thema bereits gesprochen es
ist auch ihr ein wichtiges Anliegen das
heißt auch aus dem Auswärtigen Amt
heraus die er für diese diplomatischen
Verhandlungen FE geboren sind gibt es
Rückenwind in allen Gesprächen indem wir
dieses Thema adressieren Können
einbringen können es zu tun
wahrscheinlich kann nur der Spruch steht
da tropfenhöht den Stein an dieser
Stelle helfen
so jetzt hat sich Frau Weißgerber noch
gemeldet das hatte ich offenbar nicht
gesehen dann ist sie jetzt erst dran
damit wir immer einen Wechsel haben
bitteschön ja vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin die Radikalität der
klimaproteste haben in der letzten Zeit
zugenommen und sie selbst sagten am 9
Februar 2022 auf der Konferenz Europe 22
es ist absolut legitim für seine
Anliegen zu demonstrieren und dabei auch
Formen des zivilen Ungehorsams zu nutzen
würden sie diese Aussage aufgrund der
jüngsten Aktionen der sogenannten
letzten Generationen wiederholen
angesichts der Aktionen die jetzt
stattfanden
Frau Weißgerber ich schätze sie als für
Umweltthemen engagierte Kolleginnen und
als seriöse und sachliche Kollegin und
deshalb hätte ich mir gewünscht wenn Sie
dieses Zitat hier vortragen dass sie
auch den zweiten Teil des Zitates
vortragen darauf haben sie jetzt bewusst
verzichtet offensichtlich der zweite
Teil des Zitates lautete sinngemäß dass
ich keinerlei Protestformen unterstütze
akzeptabel finde oder gutheiße bei denen
Menschenleben in Gefahr gebracht werden
könnten dieses Zitat ist damals bewusst
teilweise verkürzt wiedergegeben worden
ich hatte das aber in der Öffentlichkeit
korrigiert und diese Aussage steht und
ich hatte das auch ich glaube vor drei
Wochen ist es gewesen ihren Kollegen
wild hier von der Regierungsbank bereits
ebenfalls noch mal bestätigt dass ich
solche Protestformen für Falschheit und
für inakzeptabel halte und das im
Übrigen nicht nur weil sie für den
Klimaschutz anfangen kontraproduktiv zu
werden sondern weil ich es für nicht
akzeptabel halte durch Protest der der
Sache nach legitim ist durch
Protestformen andere Menschen in
gefangen zu bringen das war jetzt nicht
unbedingt eine Nachfrage zum Thema
Biodiversität höchstens im sehr
weitesten Sinn
nichtsdestotrotz haben jetzt noch Herr
Ebner hat jetzt noch eine Ebene eine
Frage die ich noch zulasse
frau Präsidentin Frau Ministerin
Biodiversität als Lebensgrundlage und
Ökologie als was vom komplexesten was es
gibt betrifft ja auch die Fließgewässer
die vorhin schon angesprochen worden
sind sie haben gerade von den Fischen
gesprochen und da fällt mir die oder
Katastrophe vom Sommer ein die für uns
bislang unfassbar unbekannte
unvorstellbare Ausmaße hatten ich will
das gar nicht weiter ausführen im Zuge
dessen ist auch darüber debattiert
worden was denn zu tun sei um die
Verquickung solcher Umstände wie zu
hohen Salz gehalten und dann der daraus
folgenden alten Blüte zu verhindern und
wie man Biodiversität in solchen
Fließgewässern retten und sichern kann
ich wollte deshalb sie jetzt fragen was
ist Erkenntnisstand zum Ausbau der oder
da gibt es ja ein Abkommen was ist ihre
Positionierung dazu und zweitens die
Konsequenzen müssten wir eigentlich aus
den Erkenntnissen für unsere deutschen
vliesgewässer insgesamt ziehen
vielen dank
der Ausbau der oder ich hatte mich dazu
in der Vergangenheit mehrfach
positioniert ist aus meiner Sicht etwas
was jetzt zurückstehen muss hinter der
notwendigen wichtigen Aufgabe der oder
die Möglichkeit zur Regeneration zu
geben das heißt hier auch auf die
natürlichen Regenerationskräfte zu
setzen die er vorhanden sind in
Ökosystemen und das muss jetzt nach
dieser verheerenden Katastrophe im
Sommer absolute Priorität haben mein
Haus wird das unterstützen indem wir
auch dort Renaturierungsmaßnahmen
versuchen zu eruieren zu identifizieren
und das auch mit dem Land Brandenburg
und den Nationalpark dort natürlich
gemeinsam machen werden ich werde
deshalb auch versuchen zeitnah noch mal
an die oder zu reisen um mir auch über
die jetzige Situation erneut ein eigenes
Bild zu machen das Hauptproblem aus
meiner Sicht wird aber für die Zukunft
sein dass wir in vielen Fließgewässern
in ganz war massive Einleitungen haben
genehmigte Einleitungen haben die das
Maß dessen was die Flüsse in Zeiten der
Klimakrise verkraften offensichtlich
überschreitet und dieser Baustelle
müssen wir bearbeiten
Frau Kerstin
[Applaus]
sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrt
Frau Mist Ministerin sie haben
ausgeführt dass die moorschutzstrategie
jetzt verabschiedet worden ist ich hätte
dazu Fragen im Prinzip geht es ja um
hydrologische Körper und die müssen im
ganzen angeschaut werden es gibt
durchaus kleinteilige Besitzverhältnisse
wie wollen Sie dieses Problem lösen und
stehen Sie dazu mit dem BML vielleicht
auch im Austausch weil neben dem
natürlichen Plan Klimaschutzprogramm
auch die Möglichkeit besteht das über
die Eco Skins der ersten Säule der GAP
oder auch über die zweite Säule zu
finanzieren
vielen Dank Frau Abgeordneter für die
Frage und selbstverständlich stehe ich
mit meinem Kollegen dem Özdemir dem
bundesagenminister dazu im Austausch der
sich heute im Kabinett auch ebenfalls
zur mostritz-strategie geäußert und
eingebracht hat das heißt unsere
hausfreundschaft trägt die trägt auch
für den Moorschutz und wir werden diese
arbeiten zusammen weiter fortsetzen es
geht gar nicht ohne die Landwirtschaft
deshalb der Kooperative Ansatz im
Vordergrund und ich gehe im Moment davon
aus dass wir so viel Unterstützer finden
werden die mitmachen wollen dass wir
auch mit dem freiwilligen Ansatz den
Moore schützen können unsere Ziele
erreichen können das halte ich im Moment
für den besseren Weg und eigentlich ist
es mein Ziel dafür eine Welle der
Begeisterung und der Unterstützung
auszulösen deshalb freue ich mich halt
auch besonders das ausgerechnet heute
die moorschutzstrategie verabschiedet
wurde wo Michael Soko ja einer der Väter
des moorschutzes ist und dich an ihn
erinnern durfte in meinem
Eingangsstatement
so jetzt gibt es eine Nachfrage zur
Nachfrage bitteschön
ja Frau Ministerin vielen Dank zunächst
mal noch mal eine Frage zu dieser
wiedervermessung es geht ja letztendlich
darum dass 90 Prozent dieser Moore im
landwirtschaftlich genutzt sind und
deswegen zielt natürlich diese
wiedervermessung auch auf die oder zu
Lasten der landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe
wie Obst und Gartenbau und deswegen ist
natürlich die Frage vor den
Unsicherheiten der ernährungsversorgung
im Moment ob das sinnvolle ist weil wir
ja auch klimaneutrale und regionale
Lebensmittel herstellen wollen also
können sie den wirtschaftlichen Schaden
beziffern der da entstehen wird und
welche Ausgleichsmaßnahmen haben Sie
denn konkret für die betroffenen Nutzer
also wirklich ganz konkret auch
vorgesehen
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter ich will
ja wirtschaftlichen Nutzen erreichen mit
dieser Veränderung und deshalb gehen wir
mit dem kooperativen Ansatz vor und ich
glaube in diesen Zeiten ist es notwendig
dass wir stärker darüber nachdenken und
reden was geht und was notwendig ist als
das was vielleicht Probleme erzeugt und
nicht geht ich glaube wir müssen unseren
Fokus unsere knappen Ressourcen nach
vorne richten auf das was möglich ist
und wir haben bereits im Frühjahr
angefangen die Möglichkeiten dafür zu
schaffen dass auch auf solchen Flächen
PV eingesetzt werden kann PV also
photovoltaiknutzung und Moorschutz geht
zusammen wahrscheinlich auch nicht auf
jedem Standort das liegt in der Natur
der Dinge aber das ist eine neue
Einkommensmöglichkeit für solche Böden
und ich hatte das Greifswald mortzentrum
Michael sukow jetzt bereits erwähnt dort
werden ja neue Wirtschaftsformen mit der
paludikultur entwickelt wir können dort
neue dämm neue Baustoffe möglicherweise
einsetzen das heißt wir haben die
Interessen unser Landnutzer und auch
neue wirtschaftliche Nutzungsformen
definitiv im Blick da können Sie sich
auf uns verlassen
[Applaus]
lassen Sie mich kurz eine Unterbrechung
unserer Befragung vornehmen und Ihnen
mitteilen dass unser ehemaliger Kollege
Werner Schulz gestorben ist der
parteiübergreifend in diesem Haus sehr
anerkannt gewesen ist ein Ostdeutscher
von Herkunft ein gesamtdeutscher im
Herzen ein Europäer mit besonderem Blick
auf Osteuropa ein unermüdlicher Streiter
für die Freiheit ich bin persönlich sehr
sehr traurig in das mitteilen zu müssen
dass er gestorben ist sehr sehr
plötzlich und für uns alle unerwartet
morgen wird die Präsidentin vor Beginn
der Sitzung Werner Schulz würdigen
vielen Dank
wir kommen zur Befragung zurück Herr
Blick sie haben das Wort
wertefrau ja werte Frau Ministerin nach
Schätzung des Deutschen Bauernverbandes
gab es 2021
1.300 bis 2.300 Wölfe mit der Anzahl der
Wölfe steigt auch die Anzahl der
wolfsrisse die ohnehin unter Druck
stehende deutsche weidetierhaltung wird
auch zusätzlich durch den Wolf stark
belastet vor allem in Nord- und in
ostdeutschen Bundesländern wenn diese
Probleme immer drängender und die
wolfsdichte beispielsweise in
Brandenburg ist bereits höher als in
Alaska und Sibirien auch Schutzzäune
Herdenschutzhunde und von der
Bundesregierung gefördert man glaubt es
kaum herdenschutzesel haben zu keine
Entspannung der Lehre geführt ich frage
sie ist die Bundesregierung endlich
bereit den guten Erhaltungszustandes des
Wolfes zu quantifizieren und damit die
erste von mehreren Grundlagen zu legen
den Wolfsbestand in Deutschland
regulieren zu können
wie Sie wissen ist dass Töten von Wölfen
das Abschießen von Wölfen jetzt bereits
möglich und erlaubt wenn Wölfe
nachweislich Risse vorgenommen haben
dafür sind die Bundesländer zuständig
das passiert in unserem Land das findet
statt darüber hinaus arbeiten wir beim
Wolfsschutz natürlich mit der
Europäischen Kommission zusammen wir
sind an europäische Gesetzgebung für
diese streng geschützte und aus guten
Grund streng geschützte Tierart
verantwortlich ich nehme die Sorgen der
weidetierhalter sehr ernst deshalb habe
ich mich auch als Bundestagsabgeordnete
immer für eine weidetierprämie
eingesetzt die wir gegen den Widerstand
verschiedener anderer Fraktionen dann
auch etablieren konnten das wird den
weidetierhaltern am meisten helfen weil
die ökonomischen Probleme ja auch
unabhängig von wolfsrissen vorhanden
gewesen sind und ansonsten plädiere ich
dafür den Herdenschutz ernst vor Ort
sowohl mit vorsorgendem Herdenschutz als
auch dort wo wolfsrisse aufgetreten sind
dann der Fachbegriff ist Entnahme des
Wolfes ich sag mal es handelt sich um
Tod schießen auch dieses Instrument zu
nutzen wenn es notwendig ist und im
übrigen bin ich gestern gerade im
Präsidium des Deutschen Bauernverbandes
zu Gast gewesen also wo auch alle
landesbauernverbandspräsidenten anwesend
waren und das Thema Wolf wurde mir dort
nicht vorgetragen aber ich wurde gebeten
ob wir uns doch auch in der Politik
möglicherweise um das Thema
Leinenzwang dort wo andere Tiere
gefährdet sind durch Hunde ob wir uns
dieses Problems vielleicht auch annehmen
könnten und sollten auch das nämlich
ernst
haben sie die Nachfrage bitte sehr Frau
Ministerin die Entnahme von Wölfen von
sogenannten problemwölfen in Deutschland
ist nach wie vor sehr bürokratisch und
stark reguliert und darüber hinaus haben
wir das Problem dass sich mit dieser
Form der Entnahme der Wolfsbestand der
stark zunimmt nicht wirklich regulieren
lässt Schweden geht einen anderen Weg in
Schweden wird nach wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnissen der Wolfsbestand reguliert
auf eine Bestands große von etwa 400 die
Europäische Kommission hat damit im
Wesentlichen kein Problem und jetzt
würde ich sie gerne fragen ob sie es
eigentlich angemessen halten dass ein
Land wie Deutschland was viel dichter
besiedelt ist was viel stärker
kulturlandschaftlich geprägt ist als
Schweden einen Wolfsbestand von bis zu
2.300 Wölfen vertragen kann wären in
Schweden 400 Wölfe als qualitativ und
quantitativ ausreichend sind für den
Erhaltungszustand
Abgeordneter sie wissen vermutlich dass
verschiedene Länder verschiedene Wege
gehen in Europa und überall dort wo
pauschale Abschüsse genehmigt worden
sind die Europäische Kommission diese
Praxis überprüft und teilweise auch
bereits zurückgewiesen hat und auch die
Gesetzesänderung die die letzte
Bundesregierung hier vorgenommen hat die
in Teilbereichen auch einen pauschalen
Abschuss ermöglicht kritisch untersucht
wird und wir noch nicht wissen wie die
Europäische Kommission sich dazu
verhalten wird wenn ein wolfsabschuss
tatsächlich an Bürokratie scheitert dann
werden sie in mir eine Partnerin darin
finden zu schauen wo diese Bürokratie
ich rede von Bürokratie nicht von
Gesetzen abgebaut werden kann meine
Kenntnis des letzten hochproblematischen
wolfsabschlusses war aber schlichtweg
dass er über fast ein Jahr nicht
geschossen werden konnte weil er nicht
gefunden wurde und weil es der
Jägerschaft nicht möglich gewesen ist
ihn zu schießen Frau Minister ihr
Engagement sehr aber Sie müssen bitte
versuchen während sie Regeln auf diese
Uhr zu schauen und wenn es dort anfängt
rot zu werden ist die Zeit vorbei
gewesen ich sage es noch einmal zum
damit ich nicht immer dazwischen
quatschen muss das ist ja nicht sehr
schön Herr Mack bitte
ja Frau Ministerin sie weichen leider
der Frage immer wieder aus wann der
günstige Erhaltungszustand tatsächlich
zum Tragen kommt und sie haben sich ja
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag sehr Heere
Ziele gesetzt haben sie geschrieben dass
das Ziel ist dass das Zusammenleben von
Weidetieren Mensch und Wolf so gut zu
gestalten ist dass es trotz steigender
Population möglichst wenige Konflikte
gibt jetzt ist ein Jahr rum und nix ist
passiert sie haben den günstigen
Erhaltungszustand nicht nach Brüssel
gemeldet sie sagen uns hier auch nicht
wann der wirklich dann tatsächlich
erreicht ist und da frage ich mich wie
erklären sie denn denn weidetierhaltern
wenn tote Schafe wenn lebende Schafe
eingefressen morgens auf der Weide
liegen wie sie damit umgehen sollen wo
wir doch insgesamt weltweit den höchsten
die höchste wolfsdichte pro
Quadratkilometer in Deutschland haben
Abgeordneter ich hatte Ihre Frage
beantwortet wir können den guten
Erhaltungszustand gegenwärtig nicht
feststellen weil es darum geht ob die
Population tatsächlich sicher auch für
die Zukunft ein Grad erreicht hat der
sicherstellt dass diese Population bei
uns heimisch bleiben wird und dass wir
durch das europäische Recht sehr eng
begrenzte Möglichkeiten haben bei einer
strengen geschützten
tierartötungen vorzunehmen Abschüsse
vorzunehmen der Wolf ist streng
geschützt ich glaube das müssen wir uns
vielleicht auch hier im Parlament doch
gegenseitig ab und zu noch mal sagen und
wir werden den Schutz internationaler
Großtiere wie Elefanten wie Tiger glaube
ich schwer den Europäer den
afrikanischen Ländern
einfordern können wenn wir es nicht
schaffen den Wolf auch in unserem Land
in Zukunft weiterhin zu schützen ich bin
gerne bereit die Möglichkeiten die wir
haben dafür gut auszunutzen aber ein
pauschales erklären des guten
Erhaltungszustandes und Pauschale
Anschlüsse sind rechtlich nicht möglich
und ich halte es naturschutzfachlich
auch für falsch
Herr gießen muss
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin der Wolf ist
streng geschützt und das ist auch gut so
und Herr black ich will Ihnen mal sagen
zum Erhaltungszustand braucht es zwei
Kriterien das bestandskriterium und das
ausbreitungskriterium die sind schlicht
und einfach nicht erfüllt
außerdem ist dazu zu sagen die Entnahme
ist heute schon möglich auch ohne
Aufnahme ins Jagdgesetz und sozusagen
das was hier immer suggeriert wird den
Wolf verantwortlich zu machen für den
Rückgang der weidetierhaltung ist
schlicht und einfach populistisch und
das sage ich auch mal ganz deutlich in
Richtung der Union sie hätten die
Möglichkeit gehabt eine weidetierprämie
einzuführen sie hätten die Möglichkeit
gehabt eine andere
Landwirtschaftspolitik zu machen im
Interesse der bäuerlichen Betriebe sie
haben das nicht getan und damit auch zu
verantworten dass die weidetierhaltung
zurückgegangen ist und deswegen möchte
ich die Ministerin einmal fragen was
nach ihrer Perspektive die Ursachen des
Rückgangs der weidetierhaltung sind und
was wir auch tun können zum Beispiel mit
Fördermitteln auch im naturschutzbereich
um die weidetierhaltung auch als
wichtige Verbündete für den
biodiversitätserhalt zu fördern
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter die
ökonomische Situation der Schafhalter
ist seit vielen vielen Jahren prekär
also der beide Tierhalter insbesondere
dann noch der Wanderschäferei ich glaube
es ist ein Beruf der zwar gerne
angeschaut wird aber die wenigsten von
uns würden ihm wahrscheinlich ausüben
wollen weil er hart ist deshalb gebührt
auch den Menschen die das machen Respekt
und die weidetier-prämie ist und bleibt
das wichtigste Instrument um die
ökonomische Basis tatsächlich stabil zu
halten wir werden auch im Rahmen des
sanktionsprogramms natürlicher
Klimaschutz schauen wie wir die für den
Artenschutz sinnvolle weidetierhaltung
Wanderschäferei unterstützen können sind
mit den Förderrichtlinien noch nicht so
weit dass ich diese Frage abschließend
beantworten könnte fakt ist beide
tierprämie ist das wichtigste und
entscheidendste Instrument und guter
Naturschutz ebenfalls
ja vielen Dank Frau Ministerin ich kann
nicht erkennen wo der die
Wolfspopulation die bis weit nach
Russland reinrechte und mehrere 10.000
Tiere umfasst wo das irgendwie gefährdet
wird aber okay es geht um was anderes
der Kollege black hat darauf hingewiesen
auf die bürokratischen Hürden die einen
Abschluss Wege stehen die Vorschläge der
Bundesregierung wie die alte ihre Herden
schützen sollen sind absolut Ungenügen
das Internet ist voll von Videos wie
Wölfe zum Teil mit Schafen im Maul über
die Zäune springen die angeblich von
Wölfen schützen sollen wer mal weil wenn
man ein Wolfspark gesucht hat die haben
drei bis vier Meter hohe Zäune aber die
Empfehlung der Bundesliga und die
weiterhalter sind irgendwo bei 120 eins
160 also es ist panikuchen aber darum
geht es gar nicht sondern es geht darum
dass die Politik dieser Bundesregierung
die betrieben wird einfach dazu führt
dass die schafshalter und die und die
anderen die betroffen sind von der
wolfsrissen einfach in die Illegalität
getrieben werden nämlich in das Wildern
von Wölfen weil die Bundesregierung
nicht in der Lage ist den Betroffenen
Leuten adäquate Hilfe zu kommen zu
lassen und am Ende bleibt diesen Leuten
nur noch der wirklich undankbare die
Illegalität dass sie Anfang die Wölfe
die unter denen sie zu leiden haben
schießen müssen ist das das Ziel von
Ihnen dass Sie hier weiter so betreiben
wollen oder können Sie den Betroffenen
der Besserung versprechen
wenn sie sich gegen Bürokratie wenden
gehe ich davon aus dass sie sich auch
gegen kriminelles Handeln wenden und es
im Zweifelsfall zur Anzeige bringen
würden falls Ihnen Kenntnis davon käme
es ist falsch dass die Politik der
Bundesregierung dazu treibt Wilderei zu
betreiben sondern wir haben die
entsprechenden Institutionen und
Möglichkeiten um wolfsabschlüsse zu
ermöglichen und es muss möglich sein
auch für Sie die Bürger in ihrem
Wahlkreis wenn sie dort Gespräche haben
darauf hinzuweisen wie wolfsabschlüsse
erzielbar sind wie Herdenschutz möglich
ist sie engagieren sich ja schon seit
sehr vielen Jahren für diese eine
Tierart also für den Wolf oder gegen den
Wolf weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau
aber dabei mit zu tun dass Herdenschutz
tatsächlich umgesetzt wird Zäune sind
sich das einzige Instrument wir haben
mit pferdehunden oder sie hatten es
vorhin glaube ich so ein bisschen ins
Lächerliche mit den Eseln ziehen wollen
es gibt andere Möglichkeiten ebenfalls
den Herdenschutz zu unterstützen und das
wird auch in Teilen zumindest von den
Bundesländern unterschiedlich finanz
gefördert
Frau Seitz
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Ministerinnen
sie es wurde hier bereits mehrfach
gezahlt es ist eben nicht nur gesagt
dass es eben nicht nur die reine Anzahl
der Wölfe sondern auch ihre Verbreitung
aber noch andere Indikatoren wegen wie
zum Beispiel genetische Vielfalt zentral
und um die messen zu können braucht man
Monitoring das passiert in Deutschland
durch die Länder es gibt aber ja eine
Zentrale dokumentationsplattform des
Bundes die die Daten der Länder
zusammenführt und zwar jährlich und wenn
man dann bei den Ländern guckt kann man
auch regelmäßig kürzeren Abständen
dieses Monitoring anschauen dennoch gibt
es immer wieder Kritik bezüglich des
Monitorings in Deutschland des Wolfes
insbesondere hinsichtlich der Jungwölfe
die
häufig hin her streichen also so
einzelwölfe was hat die oder hat die
Bundesregierung vor an den Monitoring
noch mal etwas zu überarbeiten in welche
Richtung soll diese Überarbeitung gehen
vielen Dank
zunächst danke dass Sie auf das
monitoring-zentrum Hinweisen um den
Ratschlag der Präsidenten mit der
Redezeit zu befolgen konnte ich das
selber nicht machen deshalb vielen Dank
ist natürlich eine wahnsinnig wichtige
Institution und wir sind permanent im
Gespräch mit dem monitoringzentrum des
Bundes wie auch dann mit den
Bundesländern wo es
Verbesserungsmöglichkeiten diesbezüglich
gibt und die Daten besser und sicherer
zur Verfügung zu stellen
so jetzt sage ich mal für die Menschen
auf der Tribüne jetzt sind hier einige
Leute rausgegangen die auf Fragen
gestellt haben das hat damit zu tun was
ich nicht wusste dass der
Umweltausschuss jetzt parallel Tag und
die Umweltministerin hier befragt wird
das war mir nicht dann hätte ich etwas
straffer hier versucht auch alle einmal
dran zu nehmen das würde ich jetzt gerne
noch machen ich nehme noch all
diejenigen Fraktionen dran die als
angemeldete hier nichts dran kommen
konnten bisher dass sie dann noch eine
Nachfrage zu und dann kommen wir zur
allgemeinen Fragestunde mithin
das Herr blickt war jetzt dran und dann
kommt jetzt ja
Karl-heinz
Karl-heinz Busen dran
nein
wer stellt die Frage für die FDP das war
jetzt die
stellt jetzt im Moment niemand es gab
doch eben
denn machen wir es anders dann kommt
erstmal Herr birkwald dran und dann
schauen wir
ja dann sage ich ganz herzlichen Dank
Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerin Lemke im Oktober 2022 also
noch nicht so lange her veröffentlichte
ein Journalistenteam von Korrektiv die
Entwicklung der Grundwasserstände in den
vergangenen 30 Jahren in Deutschland und
wertete
Daten von
6.700 Messstellen über diesen Zeitraum
aus das Ergebnis an knapp der Hälfte
aller ausgewerteten Orte ist das
Grundwasser in den dürrejahren zwischen
20 18 und 2021 auf den tiefsten Stand
seit 1990 gefallen
bisher gab es keinen bundesweiten
Überblick zu den grundwasserstätten und
auch im Entwurf der nationalen
wasserstrategie fehlen entsprechende
Vorhaben darum frage ich Sie wann wird
das Umweltministerium gemeinsam mit dem
Bundesländern eine ein
Grundwassermonitoring einführen und
bitte begrün die freundlicherweise ihre
Antwort vielen Dank dafür vorab
dann sie wissen dass mir das Thema
Wasser am Herzen liegt das ist ein
großes und ein schwieriges Feld wir
werden die wasserstrategie ich gucke
gerade nach dem Zeitplan ob ich das hier
an dem Unterlagen auf die Schnelle
findet
wann wir die wasserstrategie einbringen
sie ist gegenwärtig in der
Ressortabstimmung wir werden dann in die
Anhörung von Bund und Ländern und von
Ländern und Verbänden eintreten und
planen die Verabschiedung im
Bundeskabinett für Anfang Mitte 2023 an
ich glaube so hatte ich zumindest ihre
Frage teilweise verstanden und dabei ist
natürlich Grundwasser ein relevanter
Bestandteil und ich werde die Thematik
von Dürre der oder-katastrophe der Frage
von Einleitungen in Gewässern auch auf
der Kurs bevorstehenden
Umweltministerkonferenz mit dem
Bundesländern in Goslar in zwei Wochen
thematisieren
Präsidentin vielen Dank dass ich die
Nachfrage stellen kann ich habe eine
erst mal danke für die Antwort Frau
Ministerin große Industrieansiedlung wie
beispielsweise Tesla in Brandenburg
aber auch der steigende
bewässerungsbedarf in der Landwirtschaft
der Konzentrationsprozess in der
Getränkeindustrie und auch wachsende
wasserverbräuche zur Bewässerung von
Grünanlagen und Gärten in Dürrezeiten
führen vielerorts zu steigenden
Grundwasserentnahmen gleichzeitig
genehmigen die zuständigen Behörden
Grundwasserentnahmen auf der Grundlage
veralteter oder nicht vorhandener
Gesamtübersichten zu Grundwasserleitern
und darum Frau Ministerin frage ich sie
wie will die Bundesregierung eine
Übernutzung des Grundwassers verhindern
ich teile Ihre Besorgnis die sie durch
die Zitate zum Ausdruck gebracht haben
wir haben in der Wasserstraße Strategie
Ziele
freiwillig vielleicht kurz benennen die
damit zu tun haben aufgeführt das ist
hochwertiges bezahlbares Trinkwasser
geben soll auch in 30 Jahren in
Deutschland dazu gehört dass es sauberes
Grundwasser gibt dass unser Grundwasser
und die anderen Gewässer gegen die
Auswirkungen der Klimakrise resilienter
werden müssen und dass wir unsere
Infrastruktur Landnutzung und
Stadtentwicklung an die Folgen der
Klimakrise Klammer auf weniger Wasser
weniger Regen Klammer zu anpassen müssen
das heißt die Ziele ich gehe davon aus
dass sie diese unterstützen können dort
sind wir auf dem richtigen Weg die
Instrumente die ich von der Bundesebene
aus entwickeln soll entwickeln möchte
werden nur gemeinsam mit den Ländern
möglich sein und diesen
Diskussionsprozess da wird nicht leicht
sein werde ich vorantreiben kann Ihnen
aber noch nicht sagen welche Instrumente
letztendlich finden werden
vielen Dank damit sind alle Fraktionen
einmal zu Wort gekommen und ich bedanke
mich bei Ihnen Frau Ministerin für die
Beantwortung der Fragen und beende die
Befragung und komme damit zu
Tagesordnungspunkt 4 nämlich der
Fragestunde
die Fragen werden in der üblichen
Reihenfolge aufgerufen sie stehen auf
Drucksache 2042 76 wir beginnen mit dem
Geschäftsbereich des Bundesministeriums
für Inneres und Heimat zur Beantwortung
steht bereit der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Johann Saathoff in der
ersten Frage des Abgeordneten Peterka
geht es um die Sensibilisierung von
Betreibern kritischer Infrastruktur für
Attacken auf ihre Anlagen
ja guten Tag frau Präsidentin Herr
preterka grundsätzlich erfolgt die
Mehrzahl der Kontakte zu Betreibern
kritischer Infrastruktur jeweils fachsp